hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast
what's going on how are you how's it
going sorry all right
all right let's do it let's do it end of
a long [ __ ] day
just when you think the day is over you
realize you got more [ __ ] to do in the
morning
so you got to knock out your podcast
tonight
oh yeah oh yeah i was sitting down
[ __ ] settling in watching my [ __ ]
bruins
playing the filthy the filthy ones the
philadelphia flyers
bruins go up 12 seconds in
david pastnak with the brand new bionic
hip he
shoots he scores bruins up one to
nothing and after that it was a [ __ ]
show
[ __ ] flyers scored out what the [ __ ]
they were up like three to one
they went up three to one last two games
we
we've been down three three to nothing
played the capitals over the weekend
right we went down on saturday and on
monday we went down
three goals both games both games the
bruins came back they tied it up
all right saturday night game we went
into overtime with the capitals who are
leading the eastern division or whatever
[ __ ] division we are in
right as we get into overtime [ __ ]
ovechkin with the [ __ ] laser nobody
in front just pure [ __ ] natural
goddamn russian ability just blasted the
puck right past tukharask
gave me all right there fred we still
got a point though
and we were down three nothing right
well i already talked about in the
podcast i told you frederick was gonna
fight wilson
told you um didn't have to be a genius
to figure that out
um he did right against him too and i
was glad that wilson did not
get any solid punches in because that is
a tough [ __ ] dude
uh so we were down three nothing monday
night came back
um to tie it up in regulation
went ahead on who the [ __ ] scored i keep
thinking it's corrally but it wasn't the
big defenseman
six foot five guy he [ __ ] scored and
then i think marshawn had the empty
netter we had to win
five three so tonight we went up one
nothing next you know we're down three
to one
pasta gets a [ __ ] hat trick ties it
up with like five
seconds left three to three we go into
overtime
and the captain patrice bergeron puts it
away
for two points so um i got to tell you
you know playing the capitals over the
weekend
seeing the dano shower looking as good
as he's always looked
i know we got a ton of [ __ ] for not
resigning the guy but uh
we are a really really really [ __ ]
young team right now a lot of young
people
on the team and they're all playing
great
so um i kind of get it i think it worked
out for everybody and i'm really happy
for char that he went
to a contender and he has an opportunity
to win another cup or whatever so you
know if the bruins get knocked out of
the playoffs i will be rooting for the
capitals
and uh zadenoshara that's what i'm gonna
do so
i'm settling in i'm relaxing right
daddy's got himself a little root beer
this is as
[ __ ] crazy as i get now i'm all out
of cigars
the humidor has been put away i will
only smoke cigars when invited out with
friends that's what i'm doing now and i
got to tell you this afternoon oh
this afternoon it just so happened my
wife took my beautiful little baby boy
who's just the best i swear to god he
stood up by himself today on the couch i
freaked out i think i scared him a
little bit
you know he was standing there and he
kind of let go of me he was just
standing up i think a little bit he was
cheating a little bit leaning into my
hip
but he was standing up and he sort of
balanced himself and i just yelled at
him like he's standing up
his face got all twisted like what the
[ __ ] was that
he started crying i was like oh i'm
sorry buddy i'm sorry i was proud of you
sorry buddy
um plus he's teething and everything so
the poor guy and i gotta tell you
kind of a cool story uh my wife said to
me because he was teething she goes you
got any jack daniels or anything
and i'm like i don't even know what i
got left i haven't drank you know
forever 800 days by the way the other
day celebrate 800 days no booze
so i actually have a bottle
of kentucky bourbon that i had never
opened
uh called the duke and uh
it's john wayne's family is uh
makes this bourbon smells delicious i
didn't have any but it was given to me
as a gift
when i did the mandalorian by brendan
wayne
john wayne's grandson and
uh he gave it to me because he's one of
the coolest people i've ever worked with
he he's the guy in the boba fett suit
whatever whatever
star wars terminology he's supposed to
say mandalorian thing
so i thought it was pretty cool that my
son
the first booze that he got was from the
lineage
the lineage of john wayne how [ __ ]
cool is that via star wars
because he was teething
[Laughter]
and you know what was funny at first he
made a face and then he liked it and i
was just like ah he's a chip off the old
block
and then my wife goes come on over he's
his
breath smells like booze we were
cracking up
um i don't even know if it works but
that was an old an old
school thing that uh mothers used to do
back in the day when uh
babies with teethings they put a little
booze a little whiskey on their gums to
try to numb it a little
i don't know anyways why the [ __ ] is
this
[ __ ] air conditioning on right now
ah the [ __ ] knows i give up i give up um
i give up with this [ __ ] i don't give up
i'm just gonna keep fixing it because
i'm not [ __ ] leaving
i'm not leaving i am not [ __ ] leaving
and uh
that's it and you know my wife was
talking about possibly getting some
i don't know furniture or some dumb [ __ ]
i'm just like no we're not
we're not okay my parents have had the
same couches for like 40 years they just
get them reupholstered all right i'm not
doing this [ __ ]
okay this you know what the problem is
this is like nine million [ __ ] shows
out there where they're just doing
makeovers everything is a [ __ ]
makeover when i was a kid
nobody did a makeover when you bought a
house she just [ __ ] moved in
and that was it you fixed [ __ ] as it
broke but you didn't come in like going
like everything
has to look the way i want it to
and just gut the [ __ ] house so
i don't know i'm just kind of like uh i
felt good about it i was just like yeah
no we're not
i'm not doing that i'm not doing that
really really i'm not doing that i'll do
something else you want to go on a
little [ __ ] vacation uh why don't we
do that
okay but i'm not i'm not i'm not getting
into this i'm buying a new living room
set
once a decade i'm not doing it all right
we're gonna stay on these [ __ ]
couches we're gonna die here
that's how i look at [ __ ] that's how i
[ __ ] look at it
um so anyway i got the celtics on the
background i've been watching uh dude
just you know i don't know i've
one [ __ ] thing i have enjoyed during
all of this [ __ ] craziness
is my ability to be home with my kids
and then also watch sports and i'm
getting them into uh
i'm getting like my daughter's like
getting into the bruins
and she said ac dc today when i drove
her to school and i almost [ __ ]
crashed the car
i was like oh my god it's one of the
greatest things you've ever
said um
so anyway yeah we beat the warriors last
night
and uh we get to start off this west
coast swing here it's weird going on the
west coast we're playing everybody but
the [ __ ] lakers we already played
them
um lost to them but play competitively
and i've been watching a little bit of
the brooklyn nets in the in the pelicans
i've been watching just watching a ton
of sports i'm really enjoying like james
harden is one of the fun
most fun players to watch offensively he
scores and then like when you watch him
on defense might the funniest [ __ ] ever
he's he's the worst defender in the
[ __ ] league and what i love is
is he knows he stinks so he tries to he
points at other players on his team
where
they should be and it's just like james
have you ever watched film or your
[ __ ] defense
who the [ __ ] are you to tell anybody
where they should be on d
so yeah he's like telling other guys
where they're supposed to be why he's
like giving his guy a 15-foot [ __ ]
cushion
his defense is basically i think he said
you know you scored 35 i'll score 40.
there you go i'm a plus five go [ __ ]
yourself
um great beard though you got to give it
up man he has a great
old that's like a 1970s
like beard you know what i mean it's not
like the ones the kids have today where
it's all you know
it like it you know like they have like
a fade and then the beard is faded in
and it's all like [ __ ]
i mean just laser straight he's got that
old school
like you just let it grow you know
[ __ ] santa claus i like it i approve
okay i approve of that goddamn beard i
do not approve of his [ __ ] defense
but it is
it is [ __ ] hilarious to watch
i've never seen a guy a superstar
i'm trying to think the last time i saw
a superstar
that bad at something would be shaq with
free throws
where it was just he sucked at him he
knew he sucked and he didn't give a [ __ ]
and i remember charles barkley a long
time ago said if shaq could hit a file
uh a foul shot he would own every
offensive record
at the end of his career because that
was that thing it was like
all right well we can't stop this guy so
they just follow him hacker shaq
remember that way back in the day
um anyway
and now look now they're both analysts
on the best [ __ ] basketball show out
there the one was it a
t tbs tnt whatever the hell it is that's
that's how much [ __ ] time i have free
time i have i'm doing my first goddamn
show since december
doing one of these parking lot shows and
i don't even think about stand-up or my
[ __ ] act anymore
and i gotta get it together because i'm
going to be doing a benefit
show uh i'll have more details
um coming up uh
in the next week i'm gonna do like a
zoom show
it's gonna be like 10 bucks and it's
gonna uh help some kid
out who had a really a really tragic uh
event to happen to him um so we're just
putting it together so i can't say what
it is yet
um so anyway um what else what else oh
joe biden he ain't [ __ ] around huh
joe biden is not [ __ ] around
did i call it or did i call it he's
already starting [ __ ] with [ __ ] iran
he got yeah the nuclear weapons
it's like isn't that what the [ __ ] we
said about iraq
we went in there and found nothing
and we've yet to address it we've been
there for 20 [ __ ] years
he's got weapons of mass destruction we
found
nothing
nothing and a handful of corporations
made a ton of [ __ ] money and we are
still
[ __ ] there and now this forgetful
freddie guy is going in there and he's
already starting [ __ ] with him but
there's one thing i don't understand
how come we're allowed to have the bomb
right but other countries can't have it
because we
say so that doesn't sound right to me
it's like we're having a fight you have
brass knuckles i should be able to have
brass knuckle like what are we doing
here
it's just fisticuffs is it a knife fight
gun
oh you got a nuclear warhead well [ __ ]
evidently we need one of those too
no no not fair
you can't handle the responsibility like
we can
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm just [ __ ] around i have no idea i
don't understand why they can't have it
doesn't everybody basically [ __ ]
knows if you use it it's the end of the
war
it's the dumbest thing ever it really is
it's sort of
it's i would say it's sort of the uh
i'm trying to think of a good
you know what it's it's it's the weapon
version of the the bugatti
which is the ugliest supercar i've ever
seen in my life it looks like a [ __ ]
edzel
that you lowered down to the ground i
just don't get that car
i know it's super fast but a million
dollars for that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
one speed bump and you do 200 grand
worth of damage
dude if you own that car and you never
take it to the track you are a [ __ ]
jerk-off and you deserve the
gold-digging [ __ ]
that you [ __ ] attract with that thing
there i said it okay i'm done
i'm done all right i said it i'm being
[ __ ] dangerous here
um no i could never be as dangerous as
chrissy teigen
i i literally have nothing to [ __ ]
talk about right now i'm not on the road
i got no [ __ ] story so now my wife
has me into twitter gossip
and uh chrissy teigen was
let's say what's the most expensive
thing you've ever you've eaten
that you thought sucked she's like one
time john and i were at a restaurant and
the waiter recommended a nice cabernet
we got the bill and it was thirteen
thousand dollars how do you casually
recommend that wine
we'd even finish it and it and it it had
been cleared
um so all these people
just say this is like [ __ ] tone-deaf
all this [ __ ] [ __ ] right why are
people upset that she can afford to have
a 13 000
bottle of wine good for her she made it
all these other people getting offend
that's like totally tone deaf as i sit
here
with my own struggles wearing [ __ ] that
was made in a sweatshop by people i
could give a [ __ ] about i want to get
offended by
chrissy [ __ ] teegan and her goddamn
13 000 bottle of cabernet
uh shout out to that waiter
i slipped it right by him
i'll take 20 on this what is that
20 on that is like [ __ ] 20 2600 bucks
right did i do that right 13 times 2 is
26 and i threw a couple zeros at the end
i'm gonna say 2 600 bucks
well 20 wait did i do that
20 yeah that's right it'd be 200
on the grand 2 grand
on 10 grand and then another 600 bucks 2
600 bucks there i did it ah look at that
huh
public schools we need to get back to
the public schools
um anyways oh look at ty's tyson oh
taking it to the rack i got the [ __ ]
celtics game on in the background
love and life loving life as much as i
can right now
um how the [ __ ] are we down to
sacramento 59 55.
ty's going to the line he gets the first
one
gotta love those tall white guys from
[ __ ] europe
they don't bang underneath all tice does
the usual frat they're usually kind of
fragile the big white guys you know but
they [ __ ] they're like nine feet tall
and they can they can hit a
three-pointer
like andrew tony back in the day tys
hits them both
59-57 to stack the third
quarter um
sacramento's got a nice floor when they
go with the blue and the black i like
that
i haven't watched hooping [ __ ]
forever
i think if anybody scores over 40 points
in the nba don't they automatically
become a laker
is that how that works i'm not sure um
[ __ ] stupid league it's fun though
it's a fun game to watch
all right plowing ahead here this is
hilarious after just saying that dude
what the [ __ ] they got some
what is that that german crest they have
that looks like some [ __ ] nazi [ __ ]
center court of the kings where does
loin brows sponsor them
something's going on sacramento kings
when did they when did their mascot
become like a lion
i don't know all right old freckles is
back in therapy
and i actually had a really productive
therapy session today where i kind of
learned
and my therapist tell me that you're
carrying around a lot of [ __ ] and it's
killing you
it's just like oh [ __ ] well how do you
let go of that stuff and uh
this person's trying to teach me how to
let go of [ __ ]
be [ __ ] hilarious if i learned how to
do that i just became this really nice
person right and then all you guys left
me because you didn't think i was funny
anymore because i didn't have the anger
and you were like yeah man he [ __ ]
blew it he had the whole career
being this pissed off orange bald man
and then he got happy and then it all
went away right then you guys count me
out
and then i come back with my clean
christian act
and i start doing [ __ ] arenas across
the land i start doing mega churches
and you know what i'd probably make even
more money
you know be all kinds of [ __ ] women
throwing their jesus panties at me and
[ __ ] you know
there's a there's a million ways to skin
a cat right you can go clean
you can go puppets you can go puppets
and clean you can go puppets and dirty
you can go puppets and magic you can go
magic and dirty you can go magic clean
right you can go topical you can go
political you can tell stories
there's a [ __ ] million ways to stand
up there for a goddamn hour
and entertain a segment of the [ __ ]
population
you know you can go on twitter and talk
about how you drank a thirteen thousand
dollar bottle or a bottle of cabernet
i gotta tell you something man like
everybody's going after her what about
the [ __ ] waiter
slipping that in because you cuz your
husband's got a bunch of grammys
you know you just slip in a 13 000
bottle of cabernet i didn't know that
you could buy a 13
out cabernet i thought that like was
just regular people wine
you know i always thought like those
super expensive
did just tyson a [ __ ] three stealing
them all about according to
it dude jaylen brown and [ __ ] jason
tatum are the best one-two punch they're
saying highest scoring thing since larry
bird and kevin mchale it is their team
and it's their [ __ ] team
i'm telling you i'm telling you
if i was running this team i would trade
uh walker and i would get a [ __ ] big
man because those two kids
can run the back court and i know this
because i just started watching the nba
again
um that's what i would do
that's what i would do having never even
coached a [ __ ] third grade basketball
team that is exactly
what i would do so i think with the
chrissy teigen thing the the the real
point of that story is what the where
the [ __ ] does that waiter get off
putting a 13 000 bottle of wine on the
[ __ ] table
and not telling either one of them about
it i found that more shocking than
than the fact that they were drinking a
13 000 bottle of wine i would think
i would think with all the grammys and
how talented her husband is and she's a
[ __ ] supermodel i would think their
hot tub is filled with that [ __ ]
right
kind of [ __ ] [ __ ] i love these
[ __ ] [ __ ] to take the time to get
offended by a [ __ ] goddamn tweet once
you when did you grow up
all right you got a place to live
do you flip a switch and you got heat
and you flip another one you got ac
do you got a flat screen tv well then
shut the [ __ ] up you're doing better
than [ __ ]
probably at least 70 of people in the
world you're doing better than
do you ever think if you believe in god
what god thinks of american prayers
[Laughter]
lord jesus if you can hear me i'm trying
to lose weight but these bacon double
cheeseburger specials are [ __ ]
killing me man
can you imagine when he clicks over to
our prayers
you have to listen into people who are
really struggling in some country
you know that that sits on oil and all
of a sudden another country's bombing
them
right and or are they [ __ ] they're in
the middle of some genocide
goddamn [ __ ] or whatever the hell
they're involved in
like real prayers and then he's got to
listen to us
please god let that last pair of jordan
ones be there in my
size tomorrow please can you please make
that happen for me
and meanwhile he was just listening to
the person who had to make those jordan
once
who makes like [ __ ] three dollars a
month
going please god when i try to jump out
of this sweatshop tomorrow can you
please
make the net be weak enough that it
doesn't break my fall and i actually hit
the ground and i just die can you do
that for me
um sorry all right
that's a little tone-deaf it's a little
tone deaf
shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] [ __ ] whining
[ __ ] babies all right here we go i
don't even know what i'm talking about
at this point okay
i'm just having a good time i got a
basketball game on i just finished a
[ __ ] root beer
you know i mean this is about as
exciting as it gets for me these days
dude what is that
[ __ ] crazy looking lion
in the center corner of the of the
sacramento kings
that reminds me that jim carrey movie uh
the cable guy
when they went to that medieval manor
place
dab dab dab mass man going down all
right there we go
hymns the best way to prevent more hair
loss is to do something about it while
you still have some
why do guys turn to weird solutions or
do nothing hey
when they can turn to medicine and
science
for hims.com is the solution a one-stop
shop for hair loss
skin care sexual wellness for men
right you're gonna get your hair back
they're gonna clear up your skin
and your [ __ ] dick is gonna be
saluting the flag
it's time to write a new chapter
everybody one in which you got hair
and i don't just mean on your balls or
on your back you got it up there like a
weatherman
blowing in the breeze at first it was a
tropical storm it has now been
upgraded to a hurricane you're gonna
have that kind of [ __ ] hair
standing out in the rain here on
assignment
thanks to science baldness can be
optional
hymns is helping guys be the best
version of themselves with
licensed medical providers and fda
approved products to help treat hair
loss
no snake oil pills or gas station
counter supplements
prescription solutions backed by science
science
science she blinded me with science what
a [ __ ] great song that is
she blinded me
you're beautiful hymns was created by a
guy
who knows some men's health
conversations some men's health
conversations
are easier online than in person no more
awkward in-person doctor visits
or long pharmacy lines let me tell you
something right now if your dick doesn't
work
go into the [ __ ] doctor you stare him
in the eye
you [ __ ] tell him what's wrong with
your dick and then you don't look away
until he does
all right fix my noodle there four eyes
all right for hims connects you to
licensed medical professionals
online which could save you hours
completely confidential and discreet his
dick doesn't work
no they're not gonna do that answer a
few quick questions a medical
professional will review and if they
determine it's right for you
uh they can prescribe you medication to
treat hair loss that is shipped directly
to your doer
today hems is giving you their best
offer yet if you're not happy with your
results
after 90 days hymns will give you a full
refund and right now
my listeners can get their first visit
absolutely free
go to frahims.com i swear to god out of
the corner of my eye for hims look like
diarrhea
that's how bad i need glasses i thought
that i was like why would they put
diarrhea this
copies going so good go to for hims
f-o-r-h-i-m-s for hims.com
that's for slash hims.com disclaimer i
must include this oh this is disclaimer
so i get to say really really fast
prescription products require an online
consultation with a health care provider
who will determine if a prescription is
appropriate
prescriptions apply see the website for
full details and important safety
information remember that's for
dot com slash burr all right
vyom the vi is pronounced vi like steve
vi
biome like biome
biome helps take control of your health
so you can improve your energy gut
health and boost your immune
system health how does it work man
number one
they test what uh test
what are your body slash cells actually
doing
number two they give you a complete
nutritional plan
and creates your custom supplement i
mean that's [ __ ] huge number three
you get uh insert name here they just
put bills bill's personal one-a-day
vitamin
the with the on with only the
ingredients he needs at his specific
doses based on his test
cut all of the [ __ ] he doesn't need or
that could be hurting him cut it all out
it's the perfect supplement my om has
partnered with the mayo clinic united
health and kaiser
and is used by olympic gold medalists
and elite professional athletes vyom
will tell uh we'll tell how specific
foods affect you
you may be eating too much or not enough
of what your body needs
bye home biomes phone
application lets you get these answers
on demand questions about food just
check the app
go to vio.com
to get your unique insight for better
health and wellness
use the promo code bird burr to save 55
off your first plan purchase this is the
best
discount anywhere viom v i
o m e dot com biohome
dot com oh geez yeah
um all right
well i'm gonna watch the rest of this
celtics game here and uh
i think i don't know i don't know what
you guys are doing what is it
oh today's thursday it's payday
i feel so [ __ ] bad for [ __ ] young
people right now how long this has been
going on like
i just realized you know i guess
technically in a month
i've been doing stand-up comedy
for uh 29 years but i i you know
i kind of did it for 28 years and then
this [ __ ] happened
and as sad as that is to me that i
didn't get to do what i love to do
that's got to be celtic's ball what the
[ __ ] he threw it out of bouts
um
you know it's just stand-up comedy and
i'm an old man
right i feel so bad for young people
when like
i just remember when you got to be a
certain age
you were out of college or maybe you
didn't go to college you had an
apartment
and you had like a decent car you know
and you had a waist-length leather
jacket i mean the world was yours
and you go out to the local [ __ ] bar
you know you get a couple of [ __ ] you
know
oh god a nice cold [ __ ] beer right
from the tap and one of those big
goddamn glasses
you know there was no uber back then you
drove you took a chance
right you sucked a few of those down
you know you talked to the chick with
the biggest [ __ ] hair in the place
just a big giant [ __ ]
you know walking in there like she was
some sort of sun god
acid wash jeans mustard colored pumps
you know the [ __ ] 80s you know when
at least six people in their head blow
and you go in there with your leather
and just say i'm only going to do a
couple of lines right
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm talking
about i just feel bad like that part of
your life
i don't know how it's done now they
probably don't even go out anymore
anyways right
you just have an app you know it just
links you to somebody who
thinks the same way you do is into the
same [ __ ] you are and then you guys just
show up and bang and then you leave is
that how it works
i don't [ __ ] know but anyway kids
should be out having a good goddamn time
not now i mean get the [ __ ] vaccine
first
do you know they're actually
anticipating because this weekend is
super bowl sunday
that there's gonna people are just gonna
have parties anyway [ __ ] selfish
[ __ ]
it's unbelievable i mean people are
still dying but i don't know people
don't give a [ __ ]
they don't give a [ __ ] but you know what
they give a [ __ ] about somebody tweeting
that they had a 13 000
bottle of wine those people i feel so
bad
for john legend and chrissy teigen and
you know they went out they tried to
have a nice dinner
and some toxic
i'm sure the waiter was white and a male
took
a 13 000 bottle of wine and and
put it on that table
of people of color i don't know if she's
a person of color she at least has a tan
everybody's a person of color compared
to how [ __ ] white i am okay
i think they are the victims and i feel
like the restaurant owes them an apology
not the other way around all right
congratulations to both of them that
they've attained
you know i mean both of them came for
nothing right they both [ __ ]
worked their way to where they are now
you know you gotta i'm tell you
something much as people go yeah it's
like kenji's an oligarchy
you can still but it's it's a cool
oligarchy
that some [ __ ] like me can [ __ ]
tell [ __ ] and dick jokes and the next
thing you know he's doing a podcast he's
got a flat screen on his tv
watching the celtics you know
anybody commit you should be inspired by
the fact
that they have that thing if you should
be mad about anything you should be mad
at that [ __ ] waiter
that slipped that 13 000 bottle of wine
on their [ __ ] table
they came out to have fish and chips and
this guy could smell the grammys on the
table and he [ __ ] look what he did he
didn't give him a good bottle of wine
either
i don't know now jesus the animatic is
up on picks all right now i got to go do
some editing see
it never rents all right that's it okay
i hope this
this podcast wasn't tone deaf um
all right have a great weekend you [ __ ]
let's go let's go
brady let's go tommy
you know tom brady has been in the super
bowl every other year since 2014
right pat's one in 14 then the broncos
then the pats then the eagles then the
pats then the chiefs and then tom brady
again baby
i think they're gonna get him they can
just establish the run game and keep
that high power offense
on the sidelines they get a shot um
all right that's it um i will talk to
you guys
on monday okay just you know keep your
dreams in the clouds
and your feet on the ground and i don't
know what the [ __ ]
all right i'll talk to you later all
right now listen to the super bowl
segment
from anything better my new podcast with
paul verzi
we're going to be joined by the guys
from the sports gambling podcast to make
our picks
uh sponsored by monkey knife fight paul
i know we uh we talked on the phone real
quick uh earlier today
about this monkey knife fight promo and
i can hear in your voice the excitement
about gambling on more stuff about
betting on more stuff just having more
action
on the super bowl what is your uh you
know as far as super bowl bets what's
the weirdest thing you've ever bet on
um i bet big money on tails once in the
coin toss i usually go
tails and one time i put a stupid amount
of money on it but i was like hey it's
50 50 and i hit it
um and also who's gonna score first uh
those are the
those are the only ones i never did i
never did like national anthem
length or anything like that but can i
just tell you guys monkey when my wife
heard the name monkey knife fight
we bursted out [ __ ] laughing and i
said i'm betting with those guys
regardless of the service compared to
the other ones based on the [ __ ] name
well yes it's off that old uh old
simpsons episode where they're in
international waters betting on two
monkeys go at it uh fighting with knives
and uh you gotta you gotta appreciate
that for a company name
you know a lot of people put uh you know
fan draft wager in it they're like no
monkey knife fight
that's what we're rolling with what
about you bill any any crazy action on
this super bowl or in the past
not on super bowls but i went to the
masters with paul verzi
in 2010 and we said what we said on the
15th hole
yes we did when we were waiting for him
to come through you're just sitting
there
drinking beers and we there was turtles
on these rocks on this water hazard and
we were betting which ones were gonna go
in first
and we got so much money going on it
that people around us were like
listening
and i had the easiest system he wasn't
paying attention i just picked the
turtle with the dry shell
he was like looking at sizes and [ __ ]
i'm like that one's getting a little
dried
out i love that though the handicap like
the dried gel that turtle is due look at
him
you know he's hydrated he needs to go
for a dip
well and then like three in a row before
he figured it out then he started
picking the dry
yeah he beat me on those for sure that
was my worst
sharp turtle racing action i like that
some turtle insider that was my worst
super bowl prop bet hosting a gambling
podcast some guy hit me up he's like
dude i i got an inside tip the puppy
bowl is already it already happened they
already taped it
team ruff dominates and i go okay this
is an inside tip i gotta take advantage
so i bet a [ __ ] ton of money on team
fluff
thinking that they oh hey the game's
already happened
this is easy money and then i watch it
live and they they just get destroyed
i'm sitting there screaming at the
puppies like what are you doing you
don't know how to cover a spread this is
humiliating
it's uh it's it's horrible losing money
on
uh animal related props for the superman
it's it's funny you said that my dad got
a tip in the in the
in the 70s somebody just told him
goes this horse is taking it at yonkers
raceway
and the horse didn't take it no any
inside tip
because every gambler has a system they
think like oh i got to figure it out
i know a guy i mean we had the uh
we had the guy who does the radio
sideline reporting for the bucks
trying to get him to leak out the
information on what
possible gatorade color we could be
seeing bill
any thoughts on on a gatorade color for
the super bowl blue is the first thing i
think but then i'm thinking like
because it's such a big game they're
gonna want mojo
yeah you're gonna want like team color
so considering tampa bay doesn't make a
pewter i mean
uh they don't have pewter colored
gatorade
i want to say red but i think it's going
to be
blue i'm going to go with blue i'm going
heads
i'm saying leonard fournette scores
first
oh nice yeah they're going to establish
the [ __ ] running game to keep them uh
that high-powered offense off the field
um
what else did i say i was gonna bet
what's the over under
i'm taking tampa yeah what do i get
three
you're a big uh you're a big brady guy
is it weird
rooting for tom brady in the super bowl
now that he's
playing for the bucks is it going to be
a little bittersweet him possibly
getting his seventh not wearing it not
at all
i am so dude i can't even tell you like
all the pats fans i know would go dude
it's like watching a pants game
gronk is there we even had antonio brown
for a minute we're [ __ ] psyched
dude we want this guy i hope he wins
like the next three in a row
i know is it not i love the guy dude
we were we weren't [ __ ] before he came
well bledsoe
and parcells they put us on the map and
roger uh robert craft did
okay and then we got the new state but
he came in dude we had zero
championships zero as a non-patriots fan
it's tough to watch because
finally one year the patriots aren't
good they're not in the playoffs and now
patriots fans find this other route to
get to the super bowl emotionally
and they're not even they're not even
going to be hurt when he wins they're
ready to dump the gatorade they're
they're buying in on the bucks
and i learned how to have peace of mind
as as a sports fan you don't root
against anybody else
it's such a [ __ ] waste of energy
to even like hate your rival to the
point if you lose to them
it ruins your day you start asking
grouchy around your wife
can you really [ __ ] on her watching real
housewives at that point
it's like say what you want about how
dumb this is but it doesn't affect my
[ __ ] mood
the next morning when i'm eating my
cereal boys are doing well again
i know i you're you're you're basically
describing my life because the eagles
lost to the cowboys must win game and
we'd run to the cabin for christmas it
was supposed to be a nice vacation
she's like why are you ruining a
vacation i'm like i didn't ruin it
doug peterson ruined this vacation jalen
hurts ruined this vacation
she goes you need to go on a long walk
and i'm just going on this long walk
thinking of how much money i spend this
vacation
and how it's ruined and and [ __ ] the
eagles you know what's funny about
eagles fans is they always bring up that
they beat us in the super bowl i don't
have the heart to tell them that
dude we won the one right before you and
then right after you i
barely remembered the game it was a
shitty game too but uh
here's another thing too tom brady tom
brady won in 14
16 18 and now he's with the bucks he's
won
every other year since 2014. it's going
to be patriots
broncos patriots eagles patriots chiefs
and now and then what you have to say is
it's going to go brady broncos brady
eagles brady chiefs i'm hoping brady
although i do love uh i do love my homes
yeah mahomes i i really like mahomes and
i've heard you talk about this we even
have a soundtrack of you going off on
showtime back in the day
he's fun to root for he's so awesome but
the the way the
the commentators kind of slobber all
over oh my god
they ball wash him it's like he'll throw
like a [ __ ] three yard no
look pass it's like three yards like you
dude
i hope you like when they first started
selling them they were like
i hope you appreciate what you were just
like dude
you don't need to sell this guy this
hard he's the real deal
no i know we're acting like you're
selling me [ __ ] kade mcnoun
paul i know you're uh you're on the
chiefs for the game how do you how do
you kind of see it shaken out as far as
game script wise are they going to be
throwing a lot trying to get the running
game going a little bit
how do you see their path to victory um
well you know i was just telling bill
before
before this segment i was telling bill
that the way the bucks are behaving
with media day they are acting like they
haven't been there before i've noticed
the pictures and the poses
and i'm seeing a little bit of a lay low
from the chiefs but
um one thing that i stick with and and
bill and i did this when we went to the
red
river rivalry and we went to the um
cincinnati bengals jackson uh
jacksonville jaguars game on the road
here's a here's a betting tip but it's
hard because you need to be at the game
but this is what happens go down low
before the game get there early and
watch the teams come out because dude
we bet big money on texas right
and oklahoma ran out of the tunnel and
they just start looking at texas going
and we just knew immediately it's
[ __ ] over oklahoma not only
wanted it like they and i'm going it's
[ __ ] overdue the same thing
we were standing there quietly we were
all excited
and when texas then oklahoma came out
and they were just getting in their
grills
and then we were just watching
inversions leans over he goes
they are they're looking pretty
confident that's literally
that's my handicapping strategy at the
horse track i want to see the horses
walk around the paddock see who looks
like they've been there before
same thing you can you can want to mean
jockey you got to look for the meanest
jockey i think
that's how that sport works um to answer
the question i think
for me i think everything is travis
kelsey because i had travis kelsey in my
fantasy league
the guy gets seven to ten catches every
game and
even if you the thing is they're going
to be focused on on on tyreek hill
and mahomes i think so i think kelsey
is somebody has to be open somebody has
to be single covered
i think travis kelsey is going to have a
monster game i think travis kelsey is
going to score first
i think it's going to be like a 7 to ten
yard in the red zone
touchdown um i i think that uh tyreek
hill is the main threat
and i still think if mahomes gets the
ball out early because
the bucks defense is flying right now so
i think that andy reid knows that i
think he's got to get it out early i
think tyreek hill will have some big
plays but i think the guy
you got to go to the moose you got to go
to the [ __ ] got to go to kelsey
all night long he's had an insane year
and i i kind of agree with you i think
they see the tampa bay pass rush they're
down a couple offensive linemen they're
going to want to get the ball out quick
and andy reid not afraid to throw a
bunch of passes i mean
you know patrick mahomes is over under
for attempts is set at like 41
something crazy so i think they're going
to be throwing a ton tonight
you aren't reading the tea leaves right
well
this is the greatest show on turf and
they won the year before and now they're
playing tom brady
what's going on he's going to take them
out
your eagles beat us at some point last
decade i can't really remember
you guys won some games like 58 to 63 or
some [ __ ]
that's your rig
no listen do you guys think because i
noticed this and i know you're an
eagles fan do you think some mustard
came off the fan bases
fastball little do you notice that when
a team doesn't win for a while
and then they finally win the fans
kind of go it's like a rapper's second
album yeah it's like they're just
not as once you get the [ __ ] once you
get the prize
the first one you're so hungry yes
you're so hungry for the first one but i
talked to an eagles fan who was like ah
man i'm still living off that other one
and i'm like dude you used to be a
rabbit lunatic
and now he's like i'm good dude i'm good
everyone they were ruined with the
championship that's where i am as a
sports fan
like what i just saw in the last 20
[ __ ] years it's like we ran the table
with four teams
new york's got like 58 [ __ ] teams
they've never
run the table won every single
championship in the four sports
what am i going to do i mean there's no
way to sustain it
i totally enjoyed it i got all the dumb
hats
so now what am i going to do i'm going
to root against the chiefs to become a
dynasty
i hope they do my money doesn't but i'm
not going to be mad at them if the
[ __ ] eagles win it again i don't give
a [ __ ]
i don't i will i will give a [ __ ]
is it some point for someone to address
what is steaming pile of [ __ ]
jim hersey is with a hypocritical
steaming pile of [ __ ] and he runs a
bitch-ass [ __ ] organization
that's all i need yeah i love it that's
the grudge you hold onto
that's not the grudge i hold on to cause
[ __ ] meathead sports fans
actually like he ran a successful smear
campaign
he really did i mean he it was all the
time cheating himself
ridiculously well and the most annoying
part was he turned every
you know new england sports fan all of a
sudden into some
you know physicist with like ideal gas
laws
guys coming out of the woodwork oh [ __ ]
you you throwing that on us that was all
you
[ __ ] and espn proved proof
it was actually a disadvantage and they
buried the story
though it really you [ __ ] [ __ ]
don't talk about how that guy
tanked a whole [ __ ] half a season to
get andrew luck
yeah oh man hey you forgot that when
they pumped in the noise he sat on the
competition committee
now andrew is [ __ ] illegal and then
stole our offense and won a super bowl
we didn't [ __ ]
now andrew luck's like backpacking
through europe hanging out in some
hostel
room goes out to get a [ __ ] hand job
the whole world
stops this [ __ ] guy's like a pill
popping lunatic with a dead mistress
nobody says [ __ ]
well and to that point to the bottom
craft was single go ahead yeah and
you're gonna go to florida and go to a
jerk off
of course you do you go look at the
alligators you get rubbed one out
what else you gonna do go to ebor city
there's nothing to do there
not one i'd love to meet the man who was
outraged over
robert craft going to a rush the big
game wanted to relax before the game get
a massage that's the boss move he did it
right before the game
i'm just glad that [ __ ] video didn't
come out thank god
no one wanted to see that let the man
enjoy
let the man enjoy the twilight of his
his wife rest her soul passed away the
guy's going to a [ __ ] joint to get a
little relaxation
around the man has money he's helping
out the little guy
stimulating the economy yeah they tried
to turn it into some bigger story of
like
oh this is uh sex trade and they're
they're bringing these women in then
turned out it was just some
some woman from new york you've noticed
how happy goodell looks because the pats
aren't in it
[ __ ] grinning ear to ear and every
[ __ ] stadium
oh man he is oh he's such a [ __ ]
i don't know what we did to him i don't
know what the [ __ ] we did to him but
that [ __ ] he's got one
he's got one for us man he is he does
have a hard-on for the patriots
exactly but you know as a non-patriots
sometimes it's a little fun to watch
all right let's get some selfies i don't
like the truth
let's get to some of these monkey knife
fight a prop
uh picks here of course together can't
wait to put the money on the table
and is there anything better than
watching the big game with a [ __ ]
wing in your hand
there's five honey riding on it and
especially
with these with these props that you
start like if you're betting you over
and you get it early you get in the
third quarter and you're just
you already won the money everything is
gravy afterwards
it's pretty awesome and again use that
promo code burke get a 100
deposit bonus up to 50 bucks and a 5
free play monkey knife fight app so they
they pair these uh
prop bets up you're gonna pick two more
or less
and if you hit both you win uh plus
three sixty so a hundred dollars
you win 360. mahomes 335 passing yards
i'm going more there again i think even
if
the bucks win the game i think he's
going to be throwing a ton brady
303 and a half i'm going less and again
i think it's just more they're going to
run the ball i don't see him tossing it
a ton
paul what are you more or less on uh
brady and mahomes
uh i think mahomes i don't i think
mahomes is going to throw less
yeah under 330. it's a high number what
is it 336 you said
333 and a half yeah i think he's gonna
throw less than that i could see him
throwing for like 315
you know 295 something like that because
the bucks defenses
i think the bucks defense is good enough
to to stop him from throwing over
over that number um and and the the
number that's really [ __ ]
you know hard is is brady because that's
right around
that's right around the number um that i
would say but i'm gonna say brady under
two i'm gonna say under both of those
yeah it's interesting he's he's only
sharp angle there because i mean i think
both teams might look to get the running
backs going
and these are big like these big numbers
throwing 300 yards in a super bowl is
[ __ ]
you know those defenses like it's kind
of disrespectful to just be like oh he's
going to throw for 350. i say under both
of those
yeah it's interesting i mean brady of
course threw for 515 in a losing effort
should have gotten the mvp that year
against the eagles
against the eagles so he certainly has
it in him but that game was in a dome
i don't know i think it's going to be a
little bit more defensive bill where are
you at with the game
i don't understand that that was another
home
how windy is it outside that they got a
for 350 if i was inside i'd throw 5 15.
you got that air conditioner behind you
man the ball is a nice little
crosswind on the vent so what do you
think that interests me why do you think
that
uh kansas city is going gonna try to get
their running game going
uh because i i think there's a version
of this where
they they try to get cute and everyone
thinks they're gonna drop back and throw
the ball 40 50 times
and if they can take control of this
game early which is possible brady only
three points in all of his super bowls
in the first quarter which is an amazing
stat so if they can get started
it has nothing to do with this year he's
on a different team with completely
different play i hate what people talk
listen
i'm on team brady for the next four days
i'm all in
i'm i've taken my medicine on brady i
think he goes over i think that's the
easier one to pick
and what are you out with my home
scrambler i'm gonna go under okay
bill what are you at are you are you
under my homes over brady i am over on
both
over on both all right well wrong both i
just think that the way the game is
played today
it's just like i mean you can throw uh
you can throw 150 yards in the f
last two minutes with a prevent defense
given up the
they just and there's just so many um
there's so many rules that are pro
offense well it's interesting too it's
in the conference championship
especially that uh green bay
tampa bay game they really let them play
for most of the game
kind of had a late flag there early
it'll be interesting to see if they kind
of put away the
the uh the flags we did some deep dive
stuff on the ref
he is he does lean more to letting him
play so it'll be interesting to see
how that shakes out if they're calling
it tight or if they're they're letting
them check a little bit in the defensive
backfield
here's another uh i have to address
though is that helmet to helmet thing
like running backs and wide receivers
anytime there's going to be contact they
lower their head to their waist so it's
like where's the guy supposed to hit him
so
i i would have a rule that like if if
you're a running back like
this it's almost like uh with hockey if
it's not above the crossbar you can tip
below the crossbar you were accepting
the risk of a [ __ ] concussion
and i would love to see them put every
announcer through a combine where they
forced them to run full speed
and they said okay try to tackle this
target but i'm gonna move it at the last
second
so yeah i mean i'm with you we're
probably going to see
a garbage person i do think we might see
a garbage person off valve maybe
roughing the passer in this one just
because of
it it seems to be the thing everyone's
hyper focused on well brady getting a
roughing the passer call i
i can't see that happening not in the
super bowl brian
still crying jesus christ [ __ ] philly
fans
you got your ring quit your crying
another another fun movie
what are you suggesting that star
players get favorable calls
no it's not it's certainly not the nba
where you know
they know where they're [ __ ] through
the nba i was saying the other day i've
just come to accept the fact that 80
of the good players in the nba at some
point are going to play for the lakers
so it's so annoying this thing not even
a league anymore it's like let's watch
all the [ __ ] athletes beat up the
math team
every other game poor math mutes yeah
it's like a pickup game where guys are
just like
oh no these are my friends i'm going to
play with them it's like no
you know you could be friends with guys
but come on let's keep these small
markets
interesting by you know setting it up so
the stars just can't decide to leave
like they just sleep on the pelicans man
i think that they're going to be
all right i think that you know what
[ __ ] the brooklyn nets
and [ __ ] james harden that's the ugliest
[ __ ] jersey logo i've ever seen in my
life with the parentheses
with brooklyn bigger than the name of
the team because they still think it's
[ __ ] cool
to be in [ __ ] have you been to
williamsburg dude you guys could walk
around williamsburg with
fistfuls of cash and nothing would
happen to you and these
and they're [ __ ] playing brooklyn
we're at brooklyn at which
shut the [ __ ] up dude it's not it's not
bad
it's not biggie smalls is uh brooklyn
it's it's kind of changed a little bit
it is amazing though to me that you
could just take another nba franchise
and drop it into the fan base of new
york knicks and they would all just walk
away
like i was joking with paul's trying to
think of a world where an nba franchise
went to like worcester massachusetts
or [ __ ] attleboro or providence and
then everybody's like yeah you know what
[ __ ] the celtics
here's another more or less mixing it up
here we got leonard fournette
his more or less is 55 and a half
rushing yards and then tyree kill
receiving yards more or less 99 and a
half i'm going less on tyree kill i
i think they are going to focus a little
bit on kelsey they played a ton of
single high safety the first game he'll
lit them up
i think they're gonna adjust there so i
think less on the receiving yards
and uh i think letter fournette has a
pretty decent game i'm going more
uh over essentially i'm 55 and a half
rushing yards versi where are you at
with these two
um [ __ ] man those numbers are perfect
yeah numbers are the numbers are perfect
i know i
i'm going to say tyreek hill is going to
be under 100 yards i i think
i think kelsey's the one like i said
before that's gonna have the yardage so
i would say under for hill
and fournette 55 is a perfect number i'm
gonna say
um i'm gonna say under
i'm gonna say dude i got under for all
four yeah kramer you're i know you're
leaning into the ronald jones angle for
the bucks
where are you at with four night and
hill i think is he playing i thought he
was hurt
yeah he's he's not i mean he's healthier
he hasn't had a setback and this is one
of those things where
you got to take a stab a lot the public
and most of the betting you if you look
at the numbers fournette's total you
know much higher than
ronald jones i'm in the jones camp so
i'm gonna take under for fournette
as far as hill as much as i don't think
he's gonna have a massive game
if he has half the game he had last time
he's still going over by 20 plus yards
so
i would say i'm gonna go over for hill
just because it's terrifying to take and
under with that man
and i'm gonna go under also for leonard
fournette bill where are you at with
these two letters
over with tyreek hill and tyreek hill is
so good if you keep him to 120 yards
that's shutting that man down
yeah i don't know if he's 99 yards would
be like if
if he got hurt which i don't want to see
there were there was a
diversity's point earlier about uh you
know kind of trash talk and
acting like they've been there before
scottie miller of the tampa bay box is
saying that he was faster than tyrek
hill which was just a
hilarious all-time dude look at that how
would you
say that you know what that is that's
what happens when you have a player
coach walking around with the [ __ ]
kango hat
yeah not trying to be their friends he
bruce aaron's sidelines has been a great
storyline
he wears the radio thing like a
bandolier across his shoulder
and he's always got some funky hat and
he's got the welding mask
him and reed are just so interesting to
watch uh so leonard fournette what were
you saying on that over
under bill well i didn't know ryan for i
think he'd be splitting time with ronald
jones i would say
under but like i i think that they're
just going to be feeding him
and trying to wear down uh kansas city's
defensive line
early um because it's all i think it's
all about time and possession if you're
going to be kansas city chiefs you just
have you got to have the [ __ ] ball
and keep them on the sideline because
they got too many weapons but i think
that defense is very beatable
i think they have a good defense i don't
think they have a great defense i think
tampa has a better defense than them
um they need to get the ball going so i
think they're going to be feeding this
guy
so i say he goes over the only thing
that will [ __ ] me is if ronald jones
also plays and they sort of
well yeah jones is interesting because
you need i need
a buck a hundred yards out of fournette
that's one
and that is yeah i mean you can probably
find that on monkey nightfight
a prop about leonard fournette hitting a
hundred yards
or maybe odds
did the line of the game the line of the
game stayed at three right the line did
not change or is it
is it three yeah it's holding it three
there's like
they're moving it a little bit with the
juice but it's basically
kansas city minus three maybe minus one
twenty sounds like it would be
three and a half but there's so much
liability on the buccaneers futures
because of those people who bet the
bucks as soon as tom brady went there
so yeah it doesn't look like it's gonna
move to three and a half
and there's also all the brady fanboys
like me who are just gonna bet him
well i i took my medicine line where it
is
well yeah and it's it's weird to see the
chiefs not be the public side because
they have that high-powered offense
bunch of big names but then you're
obviously you're going against brady
and his you know crazy super bowl record
going for seven
uh this is another monkey knife fight
game they got pick
three you pick three of these you win uh
six to one so plus six hundred you're
better off basically parlays
yes you're but you're just parlaying
these player props and they
these ones have have spread so you're
basically picking
one to the other with the spread uh
first part patrick mahomes passing yards
or tom brady plus
30 and a half again i'm leaning on
mahomes big yardage game throwing the
ball
travis kelsey or tyree kill but tyree
kill
is getting one and a half on the
receptions
i i i still think kelsey is gonna be the
guy come sunday
although you're getting a you're getting
a free and a half reception with tyreek
hill
what does that mean what does that mean
three and a half with the with the
reception
so basically like if kelsey had 10
catches
but tyree kill had nine tyree kill would
win because
the spread is one and a half so he
essentially would be ten and a half
oh okay wow yeah that's a and that's
getting wild
yeah this 4d chess over here yeah this
is right i would definitely take kelsey
because kelsey's just going to run
shorter routes he's going to be right
there he's a bigger target
everybody in the world is going to be
trying to stop tyree kill he's going to
get his catches and he's going to get
his yards
but i don't think he's going to uh yeah
and then the last
more yards with less catches because you
know you know nobody nobody's talking
about special teams i have a feeling and
i don't know if there's a prop bet with
this
i got a feeling that that kansas city
chief kid i don't know if his heart line
or whatever the kid that fumbled
on the one or whatever he fumbled on the
thing and then they scored
and then he came back and he got his
head together i have a feeling that
kid's gonna have a big play on special
teams can i bet that anywhere or no oh
yeah
yeah defensive or special teams
touchdown i think is
20-1 for the chiefs i got a little taste
on that and though i mean
those are the kind of like fun random
bets that are just great for the super
bowl
i also you guys will like this one i
have a offensive lineman to score a
touchdown
at like 25 to one i could see uh
it's gonna be a cheap that's an andy
reed move yeah exactly that's what i was
nice i like that
i like that bet it's uh it's fun and
just seeing an offensive lineman spike
the ball
it's gonna be someone on the right side
because they're not going to leave them
blind on the other side
that that is true and i is that where
remembers plays
they're missing they're missing both
their tackles but yeah i think remembers
is filling in
left tackle i don't send us can you send
does the site have every every bet yeah
yeah i mean
uh monkey knife fight they have a ton of
these uh
these player props but yeah you they're
you gotta find a guy for some of these
they're a little uh they're a little off
the beaten path
last one here godwin receiving yards or
mike evans
receiving yards uh and mike evans is
getting 12 and a half yards against
chris godwin
i think evans might be the guy over
godwin
uh for this game it's kind of
interesting they go back and forth god
won't have a huge game against green bay
but i think evans might have the bigger
game
come super bowl paul where are you at
with uh with these uh
these last three dude i i mean this
[ __ ] wholeheartedly if the bucks win
this game mike evans
is going to be a huge part of it it's
you could just see it unfolding when you
watch them week to week and the
chemistry he's got with brady
and brady loves him uh you know but you
know
15 yard line towards the in the red zone
he loves going to him
um i definitely i would take evans over
over godwin
uh in that one for sure hey is there any
action on uh
tyreek hiller that number 17. who's that
number 17 on the chiefs
that's the kid are you talking about him
right now
that special teams kid that i think is
going to do something yeah i mean you
might be able to find
they have a ton of like player player
matchups so i'm sure
they have one for him the spread's
probably going to be pretty big
on that one i'm sure hardman's getting
like what do you think kramer 50 60
yards
yeah i mean hardman's an interesting guy
so one fun way to play a prop on him is
that he gets a rushing attempt
uh they get him involved in like a
reverse or something i saw that was like
three
three and a half to one so i mean it's
here's the key to the super bowl like
psa at anyone listening is
have enough prop bets where you're
you're sufficient every five minutes
something some sort of action is
happening so you don't get bored with
the game
when tom brady and the bucks are well
here's how i watch the game
what i do is i grill and i smoke a stick
and i hit record and i don't start the
game i shut off my phone i don't start
the game for like 90 minutes
uh like 45. i mean i can't do that
everything all the dumb commercials
stupid halftime [ __ ] show oh you're
going to miss the weekend
then you get you get caught up uh end of
third quarter
early fourth quarter if you do it right
yeah that's probably
jim florentine it's better for like the
west coast because east coast i mean the
game comes on later
out west perfect nobody wants to hear
the weekend at halftime
garbage [ __ ] garbage canadians
every year um
what am i supposed to do with that robot
yeah i don't need to see a fox without
uh florentine god bless him uh so
bill where are you at with these uh you
got my home's brady i'm gonna say you're
going brady
what about no no as far as what who's
gonna throw more yards
brady the the spread brady's getting 30
and a half on passing yards
he gets 30 and a half like he's an
underdog
yeah um no i think my homes will throw
more
oh okay i don't think he's gonna win but
i still think he's going to throw more
it's going to be one of those weird
games well and that's the thing too
for his passing yardage she can throw
for 400 and bucks still win this game i
wouldn't be shocked if something like
that happens
uh kelsey receptions tyreek hill
receptions
uh tyreek is getting one and a half
catches against something else he's
gonna have more kids no kelsey's gonna
have kelsey gonna have more
for sure yeah this is my time you had
your time
you guys can vote did i give that did i
give that i don't even know if i give
that so if i didn't give it i'm sorry
oh no that's all good and then the last
one kelsey just because like i said he's
a bit
you know what i actually jumped in
during your question
hey we're having fun well your head is
shaped exactly like that mic
it's [ __ ] unbelievable
i got i got it dialed in uh godwin
receiving yards or mike evans receiving
yards
evans is getting 12 and a half versey i
know you're all over evans here
are you with them on this bill which
one's god one their other option
i don't know from penn state he uh he
had the big game against green bay
he's kind of an up and down he's the kid
who had the fire yeah he has some drops
though so i'll go with evans
all right kramer where are you at with
these i i kind of
i like the angle that i think evans is
the sneaky guy that everyone seems to be
forgetting he's the number one guy and
let's not forget he made johnny football
look good
in college like that guy's good we were
at that game i watched him
against alabama uh johnny manziel threw
two touchdowns to him
and they went up 14-0 to alabama and
then alabama had five
in a row without that was it i'll tell
you that's the loudest
i've ever heard any fan base ever ever
we were conversations
they were going [ __ ] crazy and johnny
manziel had beat alabama in alabama one
of my favorite games ever
johnny manziel had a ton of fun moments
sorry to interrupt you by the way kramer
my bad bad oh no worries and
i'm i'm on brady as well so on brady as
well all right
that'll do it for the monkey knife fight
props
make sure you uh get in there get the
app sign up use that promo code burr get
that sweet deposit bonus
make sure you uh subscribe to anything
better spell out my last name he's a
sports fan
u r r here you go they'll spell it
b-e-r-r
a b-u-r-e i don't know i mean b-o-r-r-g
it should have been beer
all right well appreciate the time guys
make sure you check out the anything
better podcast on all things comedy
good luck with the picks gentlemen
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
february 4th 2013. what's going on
how are you congratulations to the
buffalo ravens my condolences
to the fans of the uh san francisco
49ers
what a [ __ ] game huh what a jesus you
can can you believe that game
why does this sound like i'm in a tin
cup this week um
you know it's funny i actually won money
on that i i totally flipped
and bet the ravens i was sitting there
uh you know remember all the [ __ ] i
talked about last week about how you
watch the game and this is what you
should do
and [ __ ] all this and [ __ ] all that you
know
let the game go for 90 minutes and all
that well basically half the reason why
i was doing that was because
i was actually working um
on super bowl sunday the sunday of the
super bowl
[ __ ] super bowl sunday um
so [ __ ] sick of that [ __ ] so i didn't
think i was gonna you know
see the game anyways and by the time i
got home
knee was already gonna be off to a party
or whatever and then uh
you know i'd be 90 minutes in or
whatever and i could just start it and
do everything that i said i was gonna do
well we wrapped early
and all of a sudden i'm driving home and
i pull in
and i don't see the car and i'm thinking
oh [ __ ]
she already left we'll [ __ ] it then i'll
just stick with my plan and then i
walked into the house and then the dog
wasn't there and i realized that she had
taken the dog and they went on some hike
or something then she comes back
and she's like oh you're home
well do you want to go to the party you
know what am i going to say no
no [ __ ] you leave you go to the party
and i'm going to sit here like the old
curmudgeon that i
am now part of me actually wanted to go
to the super bowl party because i was
elated that i got out of work early
you know what i mean i feel like a kid
like you had a half day of school and
you're so [ __ ] dumb you forgot you
did so i was in more of a social mood so
i was like all right [ __ ] it i'll go
but i didn't have a dog in the fight so
i just decided to just say [ __ ] it
all right so i went on to twitter and i
basically i wrote uh
because you know what i mean when you're
just watching a game your team isn't in
it it's going to be boring you got to
get some sort of action on the game so i
was like i know what i'm going to do i'm
going to talk [ __ ] on twitter
and i'm either going to be 100 right
or i'm going to be 100 wrong but either
way people are going to react to it so i
just wrote ravens will win
f what you think you know know that i
know what you don't
shut your face put your money down thank
thank me later
that's what i wrote so i figured
immediately i'm gonna get a ton of [ __ ]
from 49er fans and people who got [ __ ]
on the on the [ __ ] 49ers you know
just to add some excitement to the day
you know that's my little world
if i'm not getting trashed on twitter
you know i'm sitting i'm bored
so um then i'm just sitting all right so
now i got people yelling at me on
twitter okay that's getting the blood
going here now what else can i do i'm
like i know
[ __ ] this i'm texting verzi and keith
robinson
and i just i just text him i just wrote
ravens will win today
let me see i got to show you the [ __ ]
that i wrote to versi he's so [ __ ]
he's so like dejected right now because
you know he loves calling [ __ ]
i texted him i'm going to read you these
texts right here i wrote raven's win
today
straight up 25 bucks he writes back
you're hilarious let's be
let's be men and go 50. just kidding 25
is cool confirmed and i said
50 confirmed and he goes nice
and he goes i think something weird is
going to happen i don't know what that
means but something crazy happens in
this game
and then i wrote classic versey super
bowl prediction
i got a feeling something weird is going
to happen that's like betting every
number in roulette
um just saying he's just throwing that
out there you know i got this
there's just something's gonna i got a
feeling something's going to happen
um anyway so i just wrote capital
letters ravens win
no no feeling just the facts
so then he goes raymond's are not as
good 49ers have better personnel
i'm saying because i had to get him to
commit he goes i'm saying there's going
to be
frank of frank o'hara's play on this
game
something nuts happens gotta feel it
okay
and he still hit me with the dude i
called it i told you something weird was
gonna happen
oh he drives me nuts you thought it was
gonna be human being weird [ __ ] you
didn't think it was gonna be the [ __ ]
matrix
goddamn [ __ ] lights going out so
anyways i said take everything you think
you know about football
take it outside and throw it in the
trash joe flacco coming of age game
today
he'll be one and done just like trent
dilfer perfectly book ending ray lewis's
career
randy moss will retire ringless and will
take it out on a meter mate
he goes no way moss already said he's
coming back 49ers love him he's a model
citizen
moss catches td pass and game today
you're starting to get stale burr your
football philosophy is getting old the
game is passing you by parentheses don
schuler
things change dude lol and i said i'll
take don
schull over being jerry glenville you're
all talking no results you couldn't pick
a winner if i gave you tomorrow's paper
you're a bum version so now we're just
talking [ __ ]
right so now he starts naming all the
[ __ ] that he did back in the day and i'm
like uh you
lose so much you catch phrases i'm back
and i'm trashing them where the [ __ ] is
this here
submit your retirement papers and begin
your broadcasting career okay
[Music]
he actually laughed at that one and said
[ __ ] off and then i said my brain and
money say ravens hearts want
49ers and he goes better teams 49s win
this game
i said it's going to be great flacco's
experience might be the difference i
think kaepernick is going to throw a
pick
late in the game all right and he said
moz is going to do something i said moss
is like an old supermodel
all right so the [ __ ] game unfolds
every [ __ ] thing that i said is
happening
and i'm ready to rub it in this dude's
face and then the [ __ ] ravens
the [ __ ] baltimore ravens arguably
the dumbest call in super bowl history
since bill belichick went for it on like
fourth and eight on the giants 45 i
think or something
in the first quarter in 2007
um when they didn't just kick the field
goal and they had that stupid rookie
run with the [ __ ] ball
jesus [ __ ] christ i actually have an
all cap i'm just gonna read you all my
tweets for the game
all capital letters i say dumbest play
in super bowl history kick the field
goal
i couldn't [ __ ] believe it why would
you do that
you know you got your foot on that
[ __ ] throat just kick the goddamn
field goal
don't give him any hope don't have that
[ __ ] you don't have your kicker
going kickers shouldn't even wear
uniforms they should just go out there
in pajamas
one slipper and one cleat right
you're sitting there everybody out there
has got some sort of injury
you know you got [ __ ] deer antler
juice in your veins just trying to get
through a [ __ ] nfl
season and you risk the entire t [ __ ]
season on on a on a
a naked bootleg by your [ __ ] kicker
oh my god i lost my [ __ ] at the super
bowl party by the way i went to a great
super bowl party
that that convinced me that you could
watch it in a live time because this
dude had one tv for people who wanted to
yap
and he had another one for everybody
shut the [ __ ] up we're in the war room
was great um
so anyways then what happened the 49ers
went down
i was drinking the budweiser so i'm
trying to remember they went down and
now now
it's 14 to [ __ ] six and i'm like
morons and then i text firstly i said by
the way everything that i said was going
to happen has happened he goes i know
it's killing me and then inexplicably i
don't know what the [ __ ]
49ers did they let a guy go thinking the
safety was going to pick him up you saw
the game
it was pathetic i loved it because i had
money on it but that was [ __ ]
pathetic
guy catches the ball falls down gets
back up keystone cops nobody can tackle
him the guy goes in for a [ __ ]
touchdown so i write what the [ __ ]
and then verzi just writes you're a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so now i'm loving life because i went
versy on this now i never talk
i mean i talk [ __ ] on the podcast but i
never before the game say without a
doubt somebody's gonna [ __ ] win i
just felt like doing it
just because i i was i like i said my
team lost i was gonna have any
excitement so i figured i'd either be
getting trashed or i could trash
somebody else
which is really the greatest thing about
talking [ __ ]
so the [ __ ] halftime show
i mean it's so super bowl is so [ __ ]
ridiculous
it's like spinal tap at this point the
[ __ ]
pomp and circumstance if i'm using that
that expression correctly how f
all the extra [ __ ] that is going on
the nba for as much as they blow their
fans every 20 minutes they don't even do
that you don't have a game
seven you know and then this
you know in the middle of it all of a
sudden it turns into a [ __ ] broadway
musical
did you see all those fans like running
away yeah
running by the camera doing that i know
how to dance run
will you run with your chin beyond your
[ __ ] toes
and your hands are like drafting behind
you we
run out on the [ __ ] gridiron
oh it's [ __ ] horrific and smoke
machines
and all that [ __ ] i gotta say something
i love that beyonce got caught
lip-syncing because it was great to just
see her just go out and sing the [ __ ]
song you can sing
she got a little out of breath a couple
times but it worked you know
she came out there you know with [ __ ]
half of goods hanging out
as they all do as they say hang you know
one side of their mouth
don't objectify earth stop looking at it
like we're objects of facts
right and then look at them when they
can call the shots
do they go out do they ever do they ever
dress
elegant no they don't tits out
[ __ ] hoo-ha hanging out the side of
your [ __ ] leather shorts
you know that dumb ass walk she's doing
web
webbing [ __ ] ass cheeks hitting
people in the front row
the [ __ ] are you doing but anyways
that's not my world some people like
that i thought alicia keys is really
classy
you know she sat there
she actually had a jerry glanville
haircut
oh is that wade phillips she was doing
something she was doing some sort of
tribute
um i'm just [ __ ] with you she had a
conch i think that that's what what that
was called
salt peanuts sell peanuts um anyways
it was a bebop reference what [ __ ]
song was that that was way back in the
day
peanut salt penis sorry anyways plowing
ahead
so then the second half starts and i'm
still a little nervous going i didn't
like that [ __ ] [ __ ] right they run
the ball
back first play of the game that was
another reason why
it was dumb for them not to take the
[ __ ] points it's like you're getting
the ball back
okay you're getting the ball back to
open the second half just take the
[ __ ] points i swear to god
john madden projectile vomited when they
[ __ ] rolled that thing out
puked up like nine turkey legs he's the
guy who actually eats that turkey every
year by the way
that thanksgiving turkey all right a
little known fact that's not even
on wikipedia yet all right someone's put
up there just know that it came from
this podcast
okay all right so then they run the
[ __ ] ball back
and versi just goes congratulations he
calls it says game's overs and i write i
go
too early too early i hate when the team
goes up big like that because then they
kind of like oh
let's [ __ ] chill out you know let's
kick our cleats off the other team
always seems to come back nowadays right
and then the [ __ ] power goes out
why am i talking to you guys like this
like you missed the game
the [ __ ] power goes out
one of the greatest breaks i've ever
seen a team get and i know
like 49er fans are like well you know
the ravens got to regroup
they didn't need to regroup they had you
on the ropes
liver shot uppercut overhand right
[ __ ] your mouthpiece is flying into
the front row and you get a half hour
timeout you got another half time
to get that zombie holy [ __ ] shell
shocked look off your face
by the time the [ __ ] game starts up
again
that was brutal because then he had to
listen to more shannon sharp who i swear
to god
i don't get that guy at all when he was
a player i could understand
every word that he said he spoke more
clearly before he started broadcasting
can anybody explain that
i mean one of the broncos beat us and he
did that whole funny riff about you know
call the [ __ ] pentagon because the
patriot missiles i forget what i
understood every word
i didn't enjoy it because he was
[ __ ] on my team but i could
understand him
and ever since he started announcing i
can't understand a [ __ ] word that
guy's saying that should be a drinking
game
no it can't be a drinking game because
you don't know every time he says
you gotta [ __ ] do a shot
he literally sounds like that yep
and your baby would be good i can't i
can't understand a [ __ ] word he's
saying
and you're sitting there drunk trying to
figure it out and he's sitting he still
lifts too so he's bulging out of his
pinstripe soup
i don't know anyways
broadcaster a broadcaster and you can't
understand a [ __ ] word he's saying
it's unreal
i'm [ __ ] real so anyways he's back
doing his [ __ ]
and i thought by the way i thought
everybody did a phenomenal job
because that nobody knew that that was
coming back and all of a sudden all
these guys have to [ __ ] talk
for a half an hour and i swear to god if
they ever put that super bowl out on dvd
i want to see the screaming and yelling
that was going on
in the control room you know i want to
see the whole build
like the lights go out i just want to
hear that what what what the [ __ ] is
going on
okay we got a problem here we got a
problem vector vector made a whatever
[ __ ] military [ __ ] that they're using
in there
till like all the way to the build where
they're like seven excruciating minutes
in
where there's just some guy like doing
that the whole [ __ ] world and
watching
just [ __ ] losing his [ __ ] throw a
[ __ ] switch
this absolutely or did they keep their
cool
there's beads of sweat i just pictured
it like nasa with all those guys with
like their short sleeve dress shirts
you know what to do during an emergency
you can't you stay calm you think it was
like that or somebody had to have been
flipping out
somebody in a suit threw a phone
something happened somebody you know
what i bet whoever really runs the nfl
he's upstairs
in his villa he's got one of those long
winding staircases
i bet he came bursting out of a [ __ ]
bedroom
trying to throw a robe on you know his
real wife downstairs couple of hookers
up there
coming down the stairs honey what's
wrong he just runs right out the [ __ ]
front door
in his goddamn robe dives in his bentley
and just starts driving to the
the [ __ ] electric company something
happened
but anyways 49ers get a [ __ ] half
hour timeout to [ __ ] a half hour
standing eight count
never seen anything like it
and the whole [ __ ] game just turns
unreal [ __ ] unbelievable then all of
a sudden they scored two quick once a
game was i had never seen a game like it
never seen a game like that but in the
end
i know and i know a lot of 49ers fans
are bitching you know because
the dude held that receiver and he did
hold that receiver
all right but they also gave you guys a
do-over on a
on that field goal that roughing the
kicker call was [ __ ] horseshit
that guy missed it and i swear to god
scott norwood was probably relieved good
somebody else they can yell at and then
he does that [ __ ] dramatic dive and
he's like
[ __ ] that's what i should have done did
you see that he kicks the ball
he's totally through his whole motion
and all that and i know you can't touch
the kicker at all
i think that guy grazed his achilles
tendon not both of them just won
and he [ __ ] collapsed like he
fainted i think he fainted i don't even
think he was hit and they get to do it
over so
i don't know as much as
you know i think that receive on that
receiving play whatever that that could
have gone either way
that's one of those borderline yes he
held them
but if they gave you a first and [ __ ]
goal you had
four downs to punch it in you couldn't
and you got a half hour standing eight
count
and your team went you know
your team went down 28 to six you did it
to yourselves
so i don't know i'm not trying to
[ __ ] give you i am actually i guess i
am kind of giving you [ __ ] but i'm not
trying to do that because
uh whatever i think the 49ers are great
i think kaepernick's the future i
telling you right now joe flacco is one
and done
one and done one and done he's got his
one ring that's it
and then in the end which is great good
for him and in the end when they they
have this
they have the like the the reunion of
super bowl winners
you know they got the big boy table the
guys with more than one
eli sitting there giving tom brady [ __ ]
hey i got you twice a [ __ ] you i won
three yeah but i got you twice
tom brady's dimple starts sweating you
know terry bradshaw
joe montana they're sitting there and
then the little the little table
the [ __ ] peyton manning table he'll
be sitting there [ __ ] goddamn
pencil head sticking through the ceiling
joe flacco's going to be there
peyton manning's going to be there trent
dilfer's going to be there that guy from
whoever the [ __ ] quarterback the tampa
bay buccaneers they're all going to be
sitting there
you know lynn dawson's going to be
sitting there going what what did you
say
um
i'm just [ __ ] around it was an
unbelievable game and um
i don't know i'm glad i won money so
then okay so then
the game's over so now i won
so now i gotta talk [ __ ] right so i call
up version if i really been talking
about this for 20 minutes
i [ __ ] uh i called version up he
doesn't pick up
and i leave him a message and say that
he has a one-game suspension
he's not allowed to call me for 24 hours
because of his awful super bowl
prediction
[Laughter]
i know i'm a [ __ ] but you know what he
ended up calling me back and we were
laughing about it so uh
that was [ __ ] great i love it i
out dude i called it paul verzi
is there anything better than that
than just [ __ ] beating somebody at
like what they do
you know what i mean it's like uh
i don't know pick somebody's catchphrase
who says oh no you didn't it's like you
say it better than they say it
um all right advertising for this week
everybody hey guess
what guess what everybody valentine's
day is coming up
[Music]
right here comes the pressure what are
you gonna do so what are you getting
your girlfriend
pro flowers everybody her friends
impressive friends i love that shut her
friends up
because they're always they're always
piping up right impressive friends her
friends are going to ask
so what did he get you for valentine's
day impress your woman
and her friends it's probably even more
important to
impress her friends look at pro flowers
just hitting the nail on the head
send her flowers from pro flowers and
shut her friends up
um anyways this is the easiest thing
ever you should do it right now
it's already february 4th okay
just have this as your ace in the hole
you get one dozen romantic rainbow roses
and a free glass vase
from uh for my buddies here at pro
flowers for just 19.99 you know what you
do dude you send it to a work
they love that show your love in front
of everybody up and shut up all those
other broads and all the other cubicles
they'll peek over and see it and then
sadly oh so
nice and then sadly think back down
behind their cubicle wall that's
you know what your woman's gonna feel
great
um rub it in their face
on valentine's day um
anyway so for my listeners uh you get
double the roses for 9.99 more so you
already got a dozen roses for 20 bucks
if you want to give her two dozen roses
double down splitting aces it's going to
cost you less than 30 bucks
you just need my code b-u-r-r burr when
you order
um what am i where am i going here
okay here's the only way to get the
amazing valentine's day deal call one
eight hundred pro flowers
and mention burr b-u-r-r or go to go to
proflowers.com
click on the microphone in the top right
corner and type in bur
b-u-r-r that's proflowers.com click on
the microphone and type in bur
order it today do not procrastinate
you know what i mean don't let the
pressure build just bam
you do it okay and then what did i tell
you about the restaurants
do you go out on the 14th no you do not
go out on the 15th who's out on the 15th
nobody nobody i'll go out on the 13th
who goes out on the 13th nobody go out
and enjoy yourself okay and if your
woman's giving you [ __ ] but i want to do
it
everybody else does it just be listen i
just wanted i want to be with you
i don't be with the world you know
let's go see a movie let's go to our
favorite restaurant and pay what it's
supposed to cost
all right here's a couple dozen roses
for you that i gave to you at work
you'll be a champ you will be a champ
will that work depending if you're
younger sometimes you know they like but
you know i want to be part of the thing
at least once
um evoice everybody you start a company
and you want to make it sound even
better than it already is
you want to sound like you got a giant
corporation that you're working with
make people feel comfortable giving you
money investing into your project
uh e-voice is what busy professionals
use to save time and work smarter
e-voice
converts all your voicemails to texts
and sends it directly to your cell phone
no more interrupting your day to check
your voicemail or waiting till after a
meeting to find out what's going on with
e-voice your calls will always be routed
to you no matter where you are e-voice
also comes with your own conference line
to up to 94 participants
on one single call you know who could
have used that the nfl
when the power went out they definitely
could have needed
a 94-person conference call um it all
starts for less than ten dollars per
month
but right now they have a special offer
for our podca for my podcast listeners
uh you can get
a evil you can get evoice free for six
months
with no obligation you can try it out
for free for six months what are you
waiting for
get on with your dreams for sick for a
free six-month trial
go to www.evoice.com and at the pro
promo code bill bill for some of my
special listeners
um e-boys can make your small business
sound professional like a fortune 500
company they can create your
own custom professional greetings
there's like nine zillion
options that you can have this and one
of my favorite things is they actually
have voice over
actors so you can actually sound like
you have this hot chick from
friggin london or something hello how
are you
thank you for calling applecart whatever
the hell you going to call your company
you get it you get the deal all right
please do it please get out of your
cubicle
um all right back to the podcast so
anyways
i watched a bunch of uh i watched a
bunch of crazy [ __ ] this week
you know i finally i i got the uh center
ice package
and i've been loving life this you know
what's underrated the sport you love
going on strike
for half a season and then trying to
cram as many games in
as they possibly can for the rest of the
season
as a fan you're loving life back-to-back
night my bruins are on
for them it sucks you know their life
stinks my life is a fan where i have to
sit there and not exert myself other
than walking
back and forth to the fridge is
tremendous
um been watching the bruins all week
we've been playing great except we
played the sabres they made us look like
fools man
they won like every facet of the game
and they even won the fight
and sean thornton fought this guy john
scott
and he got a concussion it was brutal
because i love
sean thornton because even though he's
he's an enforcer he's not
he's not a dirty player he's one of
those guys if he knocks you down and
you're on your way down to the ice he
doesn't throw that extra one
you know and uh
so anyways he fights this guy and the
guy he's basically
raining punches down on him it's that
most of them are hitting his helmet and
he's fine
until the end he takes his brutal
uppercut
so i looked it i looked it up sean
thornton is 6-2
220 he fights this guy john scott the
guy
six eight two seventy he's giving away
half a foot in 50 pounds
and i'm just like these guys
it's it's no wonder
i remember like reading this stuff you
know like when you know bugaard
died and everything and they start
talking about the uh
you know the the concussions and all the
[ __ ] that these guys get and yeah i
don't know as a hockey fan you just
don't for some reason you just don't
think about it
because he enforces like a superhero
he's like the guy you always wanted to
be
that guy who will fight anybody you know
not scared of anything you know you kind
of like live vicariously through them if
you're like a
[ __ ] like me you know so i just started
looking these these
guys up the top fighter last year
in the nhl had 20 fights 20 fights
the season is six months long four four
weeks in a month that's 24 weeks this
guy had 20
bare knuckle fist fights i mean that's
that's [ __ ] unreal that's half a
boxer's career
career in six months
it i don't know these they're like
that's just a whole other level of tough
think about like somebody you went to
high school with who the dude didn't
give a [ __ ] and he would he would throw
down with anybody
did he have 20 fights in the entire time
you knew him
and if he did how many years was that
did he have 20
fights nobody has 20 fights in six
months go [ __ ] yourself
for everybody you email dude i know this
guy i know this guy do you
oh i don't believe it i want to see the
video
i don't know that's just one of those
there's a few things right
i think all guys you try to pretend
you're tougher than you are but then
there's a few things that you see you
just see something like that and you
just realize like i am a [ __ ] i
should be walking around wearing a dress
and then that guy john scott actually
said he was he was legitimately
concerned going you know
yeah we fought but i i felt bad he
didn't come back you don't want to hurt
anybody
like those are the true tough guys they
just go out and do the job
they don't try to be dirty or any of
that type of [ __ ] you know
um but i watched a couple of things
this week that got my ego in check and
one of them
was watching sean thornton
fight john scott watch when he does it
too it's like he realizes the guy's half
a foot taller and 50
pounds more when they drop the they're
dropping the gloves and thornton is
already reaching to grab him
to somehow get inside where it's just
like i do not want to be
if this guy can extend his arm i'm going
to take this
punch from the stratosphere
i just can't imagine what that's like
lining up next to a mountain going this
is my job i have to fight this guy you
don't even get like gloves to at least
protect your hands
you know ugh
anyways so i saw that like my ego wasn't
already
enough in check um i then watched this
thing about
the most dangerous criminals in the
penal system whatever the [ __ ] they call
it
and they interviewed four maniacs
three of whom were white dudes and i
swear to god when white dudes
become maniacs you know i don't want to
talk [ __ ] but i really think that we
we really do it better than anybody else
when a [ __ ] white dude goes rogue
a lot of people are going to get hurt
i'm telling you
that hannibal like when a real-life
hannibal lecter comes along
and i know a bunch of def jam comics
have done a bit about this but it really
is true
you know really the classic def jam bit
if somebody whatever shoot somebody
stab somebody or whatever that could be
a black guy a latino guy
but if somebody after they shoot him
stab him and then they [ __ ]
make a [ __ ] ear sandwich or something
you know chop off the guy's hand and
stick the guy's ear in between it and
just
munch on it when the cops show up and
they're sitting there with their feet on
the coffee table like hey officer
that's going to be a white guy
so they're showing whatever they pick
like i wish you remember what channel
was on
they showed for the biggest [ __ ]
maniacs
oh you know what i watched it online
did i watch it online yeah i did i did
watch it online
i'll i'll get the clip for you so i
watched this thing
and they had
this [ __ ] one white dude he was
hilarious because he was really
like he was that scariest kind of evil
where he was uh
there's two kinds of scary evil there's
that one
where you're you're off like borderline
like i don't even know if you got a
complete brain
and what you almost have like a
reptilian brain and you're acting
literally like a [ __ ] komodo dragon
like you just don't give a [ __ ]
you know you have you ever seen like a
reptile eat something like it could give
a [ __ ]
if a reptile ever [ __ ] with the mammal
a mammal is going through the emotions
of oh my god
screaming in pain and the reptile is
just just sitting there with this blank
look on its face
as it's slowly swallowing swallowing the
[ __ ] mammal hole
um even when snakes [ __ ] eat other
snakes the snakes just getting eaten is
just kind of going it's [ __ ] it
doesn't really give a [ __ ]
it never look i mean it still has sort
of a fierce look on its face did i say
fierce like it's a [ __ ] broadway
dancer like a ferocious look on its face
but they never like reptiles never have
that you know
oh my god like they they don't they
don't have that
they just don't have that emotion
they're just either sitting there
going god damn it's cold out i gotta get
in the sun
or they're like i'm gonna [ __ ] kill
you i just bit you and i'm gonna just
wait till the the
i'm gonna slowly choke you out they just
don't give a [ __ ] we get it bill we've
seen the animal channel all right all
right whatever so
yeah these psychos they're either like
that or they're even worse they're just
like super intelligent and they're
completely
aware of what they're doing and they
just don't give a [ __ ]
and that was the guy that i saw i saw
this this white dude right
shaved head tattoos right up to his
[ __ ] adam's apple
then he's got a couple of [ __ ] you
know
little wayne shits on his face right
just a couple of those you know
and uh he's sitting and he has this look
of like um
you would have thought rolling stone was
interviewing him about an album that he
was really proud of and he knew that
this was the one that was he was going
to make his mark
you know when he was just sitting there
in this [ __ ] cage
and this woman is interviewing him
and she's talking you know he got
arrested for murder he's on trial for
murder
and he did the [ __ ] he knows he's gonna
get convicted
so he goes into jail and he's not scared
he [ __ ] embraces it
he decides that he's just gonna become
this warrior
that he's been put on this planet to
become a
[ __ ] warrior so he starts reading all
those books the art of war and all this
[ __ ]
and he immediately while he's waiting to
go on trial joins a gang
okay and one of the things he had to do
to to get into the gang was he had to
kill somebody so for some reason to
his cell mate they wanted this guy dead
so i think i can't remember how [ __ ]
this guy's
story was so [ __ ] mind-blowing
he [ __ ] just brutalized this guy
beyond like recognition like they
couldn't like
the guy was missing one of his eyeballs
they couldn't even find it
and then in the end after he kills the
[ __ ] guy
he sets up his cooktop on top of him
used him as like a table
and like made himself like a [ __ ] egg
mcmuffin something [ __ ] crazy like
that
so he's telling the story and he's kind
of got this half smile on his face
and he goes and here's the ironic thing
he go no he goes he goes i go to my
trial and he goes and i get acquitted
he gets acquitted and he goes and that's
when he smiled
he goes he goes yeah the irony of it was
just
it was just ridiculous like
he was laughing at it like i i can't
even i i
like he was sitting there going uh you
know
i [ __ ] you know put a raincoat on and
blow out all this type of [ __ ] i'd come
outside in the sunshine i mean the irony
of it was ridiculous
he's [ __ ] cooked cooking on top of a
guy that he just murdered just sitting
there like yeah whatever
and then he gets [ __ ] acquitted so
then she's
so that's when he like truly just
embraces like he got 79 years for what
the [ __ ] he did to his cellmate
because i think at that point they were
just going like all right not only did
you do that you probably did this other
[ __ ] that we just acquitted you of
so now he's in there and he's in this
gang
and he's talking about prison life
and just having like a shank and all
that type of thing
and he's just was literally he was like
fascinated the same way i'm fascinated
when i watch a football game how the
momentum can shift
he was talking about prison life like
that like how quickly
it can shift and why you have to have a
shank because
you know everything can be cool
everything's great and all of a sudden
somebody's getting stuck like nine
million [ __ ] times and he
said something to the effect of uh you
know i've seen it
i've done it he's just sitting there
just proud then they went to two other
[ __ ] crazy white dudes
one guy was just sitting there going
just talking about uh you know i just
really
enjoy hurting people you got to see this
[ __ ] video
and i didn't even get to the black dude
the black dude was in the end
and uh i didn't read it but they said
that i i saw some of the comments under
the youtube video said that last black
guy
the black dude shouldn't have been in
there because he seemed like he was
bipolar
so i didn't get to the crazy guy there's
always the one [ __ ] crazy dude
but uh hopefully i'll be able to get you
guys this video but it's one of those
things
where um you know for
basically for guys one of your number
one fears in life
is what if i get arrested for some [ __ ]
i didn't do
and i go to jail how do i prevent myself
from getting
raped you know and if you don't watch
one of these behind-the-scene prison
things
you can lie to yourself i do this i do
that you can have your little [ __ ]
kung fu fantasy in your [ __ ] head
i'm speaking for everybody this is me
anyways that's what i do
but the second i ever watched any of
those prison [ __ ] things
i was i just you know i would not last
i would not last three seconds in in
prison not like you didn't already know
that
i guess this is more for me i i once
again was slapped down
to the reality of who the [ __ ] i really
am but i'll definitely get those videos
for you
um jesus christ am i a chatty kathy this
week 38 [ __ ] minutes in i haven't got
to your questions
all right let's do some more [ __ ] uh
some copy here what do we got here
legalzoom everybody
all right you waiting for the perfect
time to start your dream business it's
now
all right you is you know what let me
just get to the point is you want you
want to get
you know you want to start a business
you want to be legal and all that type
of thing
but you want to get through all the
rigamarole if i can use that as quickly
as possible because you're like me and
you have add and you don't want to deal
with any of that crap
legalzooms where you want to go all
right it's the official sponsor
of national start your it's yeah if
national start your business month
and legal zoom wants you to get started
right whether you're starting up at ls
llc s corp sole proprietorship or
non-profit
legal zooms takes care of you from start
to finish their award-winning service
was developed
by the best legal minds in the country
and every business gets personalized
attention
that's why over ninety percent of
legalzoom customers would recommend the
service to their family
you'll be in good company over two dozen
companies
on the inc 500 list were started through
legalzoom.com
think about that the top 500 businesses
were started on legalzoom.com it says
national
it's national start your business month
so start your business right
at legalzoom.com legalzoom is not a law
firm
and provides self-help services at your
specific direction
but there's so much more um now every
llc and incorporation package includes
easy to use business accounting software
a 269 dollar value for free
be sure to enter bur burr and the
referral box at
checkout start your business protect
your family and safeguard your assets at
legalzoom.com today
and lastly stamps.com everybody all
right
if you haven't if you don't listen to
this every week and you're still going
to the post office
doggone it i'm here to help um if you
haven't heard yet postage rates have
changed again
you know what that means the post office
will be even more crowded than usual
everybody going down there to get their
two and a half cents stamp to add to the
other one and all that crap
that's why you need stamps.com stamp.com
makes it easy for you to not have to go
to the post office ever again
everything you would do with the post
office you can do right at your desk buy
and print official u.s postage for any
letter or package using your own
computer and printer
and stance.com always updates the
postage rates for you automatically
so you will always get the exact postage
you need the instant you need it
you never have to go to the post office
again it's a dream
all right i've been using stamps.com for
uh almost a year now
sending my dvds out to the clubs i've
had zero
problems and i don't have to stand in
line
at the post office it's awesome right
now use my last name bur
burr for this special offer no risk
trial plus 110
bonus it includes a digital scale and up
to 55 dollars free postage don't wait go
to stamps.com before you do anything
else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur
burr that stamps dot com enter bur all
right let's get to your
uh let's get to your questions
for the week here oh anybody see the
montreal canadiens ottawa center game
that was some old school refereeing that
used to happen all the time back in the
day not so much anymore
that was classic ottawa ties the game up
2-2 all of a sudden the refs wave it off
no gold goalie interference
you know and i know what people are
saying well what about the goalie
interference in the bruins toronto game
i'll tell you this at least tucaras got
hit
he was outside the crease bad call
bad call should not have been a
disallowed goal 100
agree with maple leaf fans but come on
maple leaf fans i know you hate the
canadians too you got to admit
at least ross got [ __ ] hit
[ __ ] canadians goalie nobody even
touched him
classic put him on the power play
third period of any montreal game the
entire time i was growing up
two minutes uh goalie interference too
many men on the boarding
four-minute power play for the french
[ __ ]
um anyways and of course they hang on
the win
i actually like what montreal is doing
though i like that they have a bunch of
young players
and that young kid one of the young kids
that they kept up after the five-game
trial he had a couple assists the other
night
you know when they beat the uh the hell
did they play when they they beat him
the sabers who embarrassed the bruins so
hey if you're not in if you're not into
uh
hockey and you want to get into it
bruins canadians wednesday night
all right it's always it's always a
great one you never know who's going to
win
the bad blood goes all the way back to
pre-the depression
okay all right here we go let's get to
the questions for this week
herpes and the girl of my dreams
i am 27 and about four months ago i met
the girl of my dreams congratulations
she is hot smart funny
and has a great career we went on four
dates
it seemed like she was really into me
and we got along great
unfortunately after our fourth date i
stupidly slept with a skank
i met at the bar and caught herpes
oh my god dude
oh jesus i've always been careful to use
condoms but that night i was too drunk
to keep one on
i became very sick and immediately
called the girl of my dreams
and told her that i couldn't see her
anymore without my explanation
now i am both physically and mentally
better but i believe
she has a boyfriend my question is
whether i should
re-pursue a relationship with this girl
or just move on and hope
i find another one like her also if i do
should i explain
how and when i got herpes if she becomes
the mother of my children i think i
would feel guilty if i didn't
um yeah dude if you want to get her back
uh you know
uh well dude did you already sleep with
her
see this is what happens when you lie if
you just if you try and be like well if
you're not going to own up to that [ __ ]
i know all the women right now are
screaming
all the women are screaming which is
fair because if a woman wrote this i
would be like yeah that's your fault
for sleeping with that dirty dick um you
got yeah dude you got to totally come
clean you got to tell her exactly what
happens
you know and uh
oh jesus dude you know
i can't judge you either because you
know every guy has gone out and done
that
that whole scenario [ __ ] around not
used the condom
except you you had the bad luck dude oh
my god
that's [ __ ] brutal
ah jesus well there you go people if
there's if that doesn't convince you to
wear a condom and not sleep with a skank
because i even heard you know even if
you wear a condom
you know i i don't know they say you can
still get it it's [ __ ] terrifying
[ __ ] terrifying how i never stepped
on that land mine
is beyond me so dude what if you really
want to get this girl back you know
every great relationship starts with 100
honesty
and i'm not going to lie to you and i
think you know dude you're you're
that's a hell of a hole to try and crawl
out of no pun intended
um but uh but from here on out man you
gotta
you can't do what that skank did to you
you to be honest with people
uh yeah dude that's that's brutal that's
brutal but you know what it's not the
end of the [ __ ] world
ugh jesus christ but yeah you got you
got to come with with total honesty
total honesty and uh
yeah and turning it turning into a
positive dude
you know you're being a [ __ ] dirty
dog
now uh yeah i'm telling you i i believe
though if you come with total honesty
and you you
you stay on a righteous path that you
will meet that person if it's not this
one
at uh you know who knows
i don't know i'm not trying i'm trying
not to use a cliche that everything
happens for a reason
um i don't believe that i think you know
you're [ __ ] up
and now you're paying the price and uh
you got to try to turn the ship around
so uh good luck with that
but like i said i would go with 100
honesty you got to you can't do that to
her
i can't do that to her um all right
advice from japan
uh bill i'm 28 single and i live in
japan i'm originally from america
america
and i moved here after college i'm a
translator
and speak decent japanese jesus christ
dude how the [ __ ] did you learn that
you know i listen to french spanish like
that type of [ __ ]
italian that seems like you know you get
a handle on it
but that's how the [ __ ] you jump on that
[ __ ] is beyond me
how they how they can go from theirs and
be able to speak ours i swear to god
it's incredible
um anyways when people ask why i say
that i love japanese people and i love
living here
um what
let me get back i'm a translator and i
speak decent japanese but the culture
barrier is still pretty huge for me
when people ask why okay there we go i
say that i love japanese people and i
love
living here but i wouldn't ever want to
become japanese
generally speaking they're overworked
and unhappy
for better or worse my attitude keeps me
a little isolated
yeah i've seen that stuff over there
like as far as what i've seen
um you know the propaganda from what
i've seen i saw in 60 minutes
that if you you [ __ ] up at your job they
send you some camp and then you have to
sing the company song
and these guys were singing the song
trying to get back in the company
they're like crying and everything and
there's like four japanese dudes just
looking at him
just ice cold simon cobbles to the
[ __ ] nine thousands power
like your family disowns you
it's crazy it's hardcore over there man
straightening their damn rivers
um there is one very japanese woman
what does that mean i've met who i
recently connected with in spite of all
that
she's an amateur artist and actress and
we've worked together to make subtitles
for local independent movies
that's how we met actually she's
interesting as hell
and downright sexy too problem she's
married and has a son
dude what the [ __ ]
are you trying to get a [ __ ] samurai
sword to your jugular
you're gonna [ __ ] a married broad with a
kid in a different country
do it i don't i don't know anything
about the japanese culture but if you
can lose face for not having enough
paper clips at your goddamn desk and get
sent to a borderline death camp and you
got to sing a [ __ ] song to get back
into the company
how much face do you lose if round eye
[ __ ] your [ __ ] woman
dude you're gonna you're gonna get
thrown into one of their straightened
rivers
[Laughter]
all right come on man
come on man don't do this
he said from early on it was obvious
that there was a mutual attraction going
on
especially whenever we were at a movie
party with a couple
of drinks in us like any guy would
i wanted to sleep with her but i didn't
dwell on it good for you it seemed
it never seemed like it was in the cards
but we were working together
we kept each other and when we working
together we kept each other at arm's
length
months went by without anything changing
oh my god dude this is like watching us
this is like a suspense thriller
dude you can't do this there's a kid
involved that kid loves
his mom and his dad you're gonna go in
there and your dick like a samurai sword
is gonna slice that kid's life in half
you can't do it
i'm gonna read the rest of this with one
eye closed then came the local film
festival oh geez when it finished we
were downtown
and pleasantly drunk and the last trains
that run
every night were long gone well isn't
that
convenient when she mentioned taking an
expensive cab ride home
i suggested that she crash at my nearby
apartment
until the morning train started no you
didn't you didn't suggest that
you addicted your dick's like
relax stand down i've got this
anyways she had been there a dozen times
already
because that's where we always worked oh
my god dude this is like some red shoe
diary going on here
i'll cut to the chase
in my apartment that night she turned to
me and asked point blank if i wanted to
[ __ ]
wow dude at that point i think all bets
are off
okay cause i thought you were kind of
seducing this girl now she's just like
oh jesus well maybe you should have
wow i didn't see that coming
anyways he goes and i told her no
okay he goes i wasn't exactly surprised
that she asked
part of me was hoping she would when she
did though
all i could do was go through what i
felt right at that moment i admit
i really didn't know what to do and was
playing it safe we went to sleep
and she left in the morning here's the
thing she and her husband who i've never
met thank god don't get along
oh she and her husband don't get along
and have no sex whatsoever oh so she's
in a loveless marriage
okay this is what she told me anyway she
has long wanted a divorce but won't do
it because of her son
so while saying no might have seemed
like the noble non-homewrecker thing to
do
part of me cape keeps asking what
difference does it make
uh you know what you ever see scarface
when the cop goes it's your tree frank
you're sitting in it
all right that's her [ __ ] situation
dude
she married a guy that she didn't love
and she had a kid
all right you know
that's you're stepping into the world of
her bad decision
now think back when you were a kid and
you thought about meeting the woman in
your dreams is that the way it went
down i'm not trying to [ __ ] on this
thing here but like
you know i think she needs to be free
and clear
if you're actually thinking of uh
getting into a [ __ ] relationship with
this person
um if you're just thinking about banging
her i don't know
dude i don't know the [ __ ] kid look
if there was no kid involved
have at it but there's just something
there's some kid sitting at home
in some racing car bed you know
loving his mom and his dad i don't know
i don't know that's
do you really want that on your resume
anyway because he goes
then there's the fact that our
friendship suffered anyways because ever
since that night she scaled back all the
contact with me they say that affairs
never end well but this isn't ending
well either
i don't know i just feel like maybe i
should have [ __ ] her
my few trusted guy friends say they
would have of course they would have
i would have i would have i know i would
have if i was drunk
and she said that i don't but the kid i
don't know if i could have blocked out
the kid
i am a piece of [ __ ] but i don't i don't
think that i i'm that big a piece of
[ __ ]
i'm just being honest all right
i know there's a lot of ladies that are
listening to this thing but you know how
we are
okay you lead us around by our [ __ ]
dick some
[ __ ] hottie you're working with he's
probably rubbed one out 50 times to her
finally just says hey you you won't [ __ ]
or what i mean
you're gonna do it you know game on
um
you know you know and for anyone who
gets mad at me that's some of the most
honest [ __ ] about men you're ever going
to [ __ ] hear so go [ __ ] yourself and
your email that you send me okay god
bless you
uh my few trusted guy friends say they
would have uh whatever
she may sound like i think a lot of this
woman and i've never
had someone like her just throw herself
at me before i'm starting to feel like i
missed the boat
then again she's [ __ ] married and has
a kid what what have you had done
i told you what i would have done if she
was single and she was married and
didn't have a kid and she was in this
loveless [ __ ] thing
and every day i'm next to her working
together she's in my apartment
comes over smelling good and i have a
couple of [ __ ] drinks in me
and she says he won't [ __ ] a wood for
some reason as a southern accent i'm all
over it
i would have felt like [ __ ] immediately
i would have felt guilty
but i'm [ __ ] weak all right
i'm a guy i'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
and it would have been the wrong thing
to do so you did the [ __ ] right thing
you did the [ __ ] right thing dude
i'll tell you right now you know what go
rub one out to her
what do you feel like afterwards do you
still feel aren't you kind of relieved
like thank god i didn't do it you know
i don't know
i just feel bad for her you know she
married the wrong guy she's got a kid
with them and then she's [ __ ]
just hey do you want to bang me or what
and you're like no
and she's got to be walking back on what
the [ __ ] is wrong with my thing
you know why isn't my lightsaber working
here i got this power and it's not
[ __ ]
it's not it's not happening for me um
i don't know i can tell you how to get
that train back on the tracks but i
don't want to do that to you so
uh don't don't do it dude there's a kid
involved
okay even i have standards you got to
have some sort of standards
all right will you just shout your dick
back into your pants
like hey i said stand the [ __ ] down
you know you got to have some sort of
something all right look
she's eventually going to leave that guy
she is but i'm telling you that's that's
not your your [ __ ] get the [ __ ] out
of there
all right get out of there what do we
got here 57 minutes in here we go
sticking it to the x should i
all right right out of the gate i can
tell you no but let me hear the story
i'm 28 and i found out about you and
i'm going to get right to it my ex-wife
and i
had been together for about five years
before we decided to get married right
after university
her family was religious so we couldn't
live together first so that
seemed like the next step um as a new
grad
was working hard trying to get work in
my field and basically
starting at the bottom but slowly
getting my footing
she was working at the same bank she had
since high school and through university
and was finally moving up the ranks
fast forward a year and a half into our
marriage and she's getting promoted to
manager
to manage a bank downtown she gets a
good raise
and things are looking good for me or so
i thought then a week after she starts
this
job she lays it on me
she wants to know what it's like to be
single again
she never really wanted to get married
and apparently she feels that the spark
isn't there anymore
there's no other guy but she just
doesn't like who i am anymore
and there was nothing in the six years
of
us being together worth saving oh jesus
well listen
kudos to her for being [ __ ] honest
and not wasting another five years of
your life
so he goes after so after some
self-reflection
and a bit of counseling a bit of boozing
with friends and an amazingly insightful
mushroom trip
i realized this is a blessing in
disguise she doesn't like who i am
anymore
like there was something wrong with me
other than taking her [ __ ]
and being committed to her for almost
six years okay this is understandable
anger i get it get it out of you
he says [ __ ] her we had no kids not many
assets at this point
a dog that i get it was a get out of
jail card a guilt-free way
a guilt-free way clean
what a guilt-free way clean way to get
out from under the
hoof of an oppressive [ __ ] of a wife who
had turned me into a shadow of my former
self
content with being [ __ ] maybe once a
month
we both move out and put our place for
up our place up for sale
all right now doesn't i don't think that
this guy really feels that this woman is
a [ __ ]
he's just saying this because she
[ __ ] dumped him um he goes i
immediately gave myself
a no contact policy blocked her on
facebook
and could only talk about business with
her until we got through the separation
negotiations in june there you go it's a
strong move i like it
then silence the other policy i gave
myself was to say
yes to any opportunity that was
presented
this helped me make this past summer the
best of my life
full of trips and sleeping with new
girls hotter and younger than her
older and uglier it didn't matter i was
saying yes well for the love of god wear
a condom sir
even after finding out from one of her
friends a few months later
that she had been dating slash living
with this guy she had worked with since
about a month after she left me yeah
this girl is like uh
she goes from relationship to
relationship anyways he said i didn't
break the no content policy
i didn't want her to think i gave two
shits about her anymore this guy by the
way i had met on many occasions at work
functions
and even when it came came out for her
birthday that year
i [ __ ] told her that this dude is
into you i don't like him but she would
say oh he's just a friend
he's a [ __ ] snake in the grass
oh this guy he's like so angry he's not
even writing in complete sentences
he's this [ __ ] snake in the grass but
she's a [ __ ]
i'm not an idiot so i can guess that
this wasn't just a lucky coincidence
they both happen to be single together
and likely why things move so fast
regardless i kept to my policy
now almost a year later i'm in the best
shape of my life
after losing 40 pounds good for you man
good for you this is great just started
a new job where i make as much as her
and in my field have a hotter girlfriend
and have won
all the mutual friends we had
that were worth keeping so why do you
need revenge
he goes all is good but i've been
feeling like a bit of a [ __ ] for not
taking her to task on all of this [ __ ]
especially now that we've been separated
for almost a year
and soon can be legally divorced in
canada i think it's time to finally
confront her
and break her so i would like to take
this [ __ ] down
and my advice on how to go about it
would be great
sorry about the length and thanks for
any help dude you're already taking her
down
they say the the greatest revenge is a
life well lived
you're doing it you lost 40 pounds you
have a hotter girlfriend
keep saying yes i go easy with the
sleeping around dude you don't want to
catch anything man but
you know just go live your life leave
her
in the dust okay
she's going to check out your facebook
page she'll see your pictures
you really want to get back at this girl
don't ever talk to her again
and just live this awesome life marry a
beautiful woman
keep yourself in great shape and just
know every once in a while she's going
to check in
and i guarantee you unless this guy they
just had this ridiculous spark
at work then god bless him she she found
who she should have been with
as will you and it's all good or
she's a serial mono what is it not
monogamous whatever the [ __ ] it is i'm
so
dumb she goes from relationship to
relationship and eventually this
[ __ ] snake in the grass at the bank
is gonna um
get the same speech or he might give it
to her he might be one of these creeps
that
it turned around that he's in a
relationship that she's in a
relationship and he can be [ __ ]
banging
this chick you know
[ __ ] him [ __ ] with their
their banker sex they probably have to
wear masks
you know have some sort of ritual
um anyways yeah dude don't do that don't
do that because you know what you're
doing when you you
walk up to her and you [ __ ] go let me
tell you something you [ __ ] [ __ ]
blah blah blah blah women are too smart
for that [ __ ]
she's just sitting there going like wow
he still does care
wow he lost that weight because of me
not because he's actually a better
person than i thought he was
all right don't do that she wins if you
confront her she [ __ ] wins
just keep doing what you're doing
yelling at her
like she's in the room but she isn't
scream at your windshield
okay but keep saying yes in life keep
going after your dreams
and just live this [ __ ] awesome life
and maybe one day who knows you go to
the same mall you show up with your hot
wife and your beautiful kids
she shows up she's fat you know
then you'll be like just give her a nut
hey
that's what you could have been with
johnny six-pack over here
oh and you just keep going you take your
kids for an ice cream and you get
yourself a sherbet
um
all right this has been a fun one um you
guys great questions this week great
questions um
okay here we go here we go last one
racism in a relationship oh jesus
um oh she's oh she says
questions for you and the lovely nia if
she's there
ah [ __ ] she isn't here my boyfriend of a
month told me that his mom is racist
and his grandpa is racist to the point
where he
he would disown my boyfriend
uh he says he's not racist but he shrugs
off family comments
and is very non-confrontational i'm not
fully black um
i like to call i'm like what i like what
i like to call
african uh my mom is from kenya my dad
is french canadian i live in canada so
i'm not used to racism
uh in fact i'm so confused when somebody
calls me the n-word i can't help but
think
my family's from africa they should use
the term oh yeah i've heard of that term
which i'm not going to do
i'm not going to say it on my podcast
because that's just going to give morons
you know i don't know they'll probably
figure out what it is but they're not
going to learn it from me
anyways um he says i'm so stupid when it
comes to people being racist towards me
i don't even know how i'm supposed to
react
obviously i'm hurt and i'm sure there's
some obligation i have to
stand on behalf of the belittlement of
society
but what do i say to what wait let me
read that more quote
i'm sure there's some obligation i have
to take a stand on behalf of the
betterment of society
but what do i say to him or his family i
don't know what i should do my boyfriend
is worth fighting for but family is
irreplaceable and i don't want to rip
his apart because he
his needs to be there for him if i can't
thanks um
uh i don't yeah you would like to think
that he would step up there
i don't look when it comes to your
grandparents what are you gonna do
you're gonna change 80 years they are
how they are
you know but your parents that's that's
a a harder issue
um which obviously could grow into a
bigger issue if you get
even more serious um
i don't know i think that you should be
somebody with somebody who has your
[ __ ] back
and i think you need to sit down with
him and tell him that he needs to have
you back and that his parents need to
accept who the [ __ ] he's dating
or uh you're gonna move on and get with
somebody
who's more of a [ __ ] man and can you
know something
if you're with somebody they got to be
with you okay
he is in an awkward position but he
needs to sit down
and and have a talk with his parents his
grandparents that that's a [ __ ] wash
you know what i mean they're old people
always bitching
they're bitching about everything so you
know whatever
um i mean grandparents came up in a time
where if you were irish
and she was italian they would flip out
to a protestant and this person was
catholic like they they were
separating to that level um
but yeah i think i think you need to
have a talk with them
you know and if that ends it and he goes
a separate way then you know what
you got off easy because eventually it
would have come to a head and you
wouldn't have been happy
all right regardless of whether it's a
race issue or whatever the person you're
with has to have your [ __ ] back
on the big [ __ ] okay the little stuff
about doing dishes and arguing about
that that's just crap that you argue
about but something like that is
i mean that's the whole thing holding
the [ __ ] thing together if that
that's the foundation if that's not
there then uh you're wasting your time
and you only get one life and you
shouldn't be wasting [ __ ] time so
that's my advice all right and that is
the podcast for this week
thank you everybody for listening and uh
now the weird
sadness of football is is
over they're stunned that
monday you wake up you know and it's
[ __ ] over there's not a game next
week it's brutal
so my suggestion this week get into nba
hoop or the nhl
if you want to get into the nhl i cannot
recommend the
uh the nhl centerized package enough
pick a team you know
learn all their players and that type of
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] beautiful game and
i'm so happy it's back
and i i'm telling you canadians bruins
even when both those teams suck it's
always a great game and
neither team sucks right now canadians
are playing great they're they're
they're rebuilding their team they got
all this young talent
and uh the bruins of the bruins
we're playing great ourselves other than
that [ __ ] game against the sabers
um whatever pull up a chair watch your
game all right go [ __ ] yourselves have a
great week i'll talk to you later
you